And Stefan Molyneux
correctly. Dancer name. Right.
That is pretty good. I mean, you
did not believe the, the DV issues.
I think some people just cough
it up with the thing on hairball.
What the hell they're doing with my name.
Correct. But it's like French, French,
not like we're back French. Okay.
What is the difference between
Quebec, French and French?
French? Um, well, you know,
like the Queen and Cockney as
sort of the difference. Right.
So Quebec French is like the
gutter at least by the French next.
Instead it would be the gutter,
the gutter, French or rude.
I know it's going to be very nice people,
very nice people in need.
And for the French who look down on
people after the Second World War,
it takes a lot.
Anyway,
folks listening to this where
we're in Toronto right now. Uh,
this is the first time I've met stuff
when I met him just a few moments ago down
in the lobby. But I've
seen a lot of your, uh,
internet videos and I was particularly
impressed with several of them,
but really the,
the Trayvon Martin one,
I think you covered that better than
anyone I saw online on TV and the media,
you gave a real, you know, the
quote, the Fox fair and unbalanced.
You give a real fair and balanced
approach to that subject.
And to me personally as a human
being, that was one of the most, uh,
frustrating, um, events of our day,
not just because a young man lost
his life, not just because of the,
the, the race baiting that went
on with it, but the cloudy,
muddy thinking that I felt was perpetrated
by the media and by politicians and
by all these people that we're
looking to capitalize on that event.
There was the, the, the,
the thinking was so disingenuous and they
were showing these photos of him when
he was like a fucking baby, you know, it
was, it was really confusing stuff to me.
And do you actually, if you looked
at George Zimmerman over time,
the pictures got wider and wider.
Like they actually applied
photo retouching to make
him look lighter. Oh yeah.
I mean it was, it was like gets
stopped those style propaganda.
It was just wretched. Wow. I didn't
know that they did that. And you know,
they edited, um, his nine one one
call. Right. Really? Yeah. So, um,
so, uh, Zimmerman called and he said that
some suspicious guy rolling around the
neighborhood and then the, the dispatcher
said, well, what is his race? And he said,
well, I think he's black. And
NBC edited out the question.
So it sounded like this is a suspicious
guy rolling around the neighborhood.
I think he's black. Like you just, wow.
He was actually responding to a question.
They edited that out.
The woman lost her job and then,
and he's now suing NBC for defamation
because they edit it to make him sound
like a racist.
Well,
you know,
I don't know if it's really bright for
him to be involved in the further in the
legal system, but I think, you
know, what they did was, uh,
it was horrendous. It was, it's
very strange.
It was very strange to watch.
You know what my approach and you know,
we'll say we want to live in a colorblind
society and I think that would be
great. So for me, I always try
to try and look at it like,
well if he wasn't black,
what if he was just some other white guy?
What if they were both black?
I want if they were both rainbow colored
with dolphin heads, I don't know. Right.
But what if it had nothing
to do with the, the, the,
this was a black energy around race,
the negative energy around risks.
And so for me, I really just wanted
to look at it like, you know,
that Joe Friday thing, you know, what
are the facts? What are the facts,
what are the facts?
Because I really have strived striven
and it's hard to do in this culture to
just treat people like
color doesn't matter.
And that means that you don't get to
play the race card, you know? And,
and I think it really would be great if
we could achieve that seems so hard for
people to get it.
Well, it's too common.
It's like, it's almost,
it's just as a natural
part of our culture,
we weave that pattern has
been so firmly established.
That path has been so deeply carved
that people just slide right in.
Yeah. Well I wonder too, you know, this,
this horrible shooting that just happened,
uh, in the navy yards. Yeah. In
Washington. Uh, Alexis, I wonder,
there's no proof of this yet,
so all bullshit hiker hypotheticals,
but I wonder if this guy was a black
guy and apparently he had a real chip on
his shoulder about, you know, I'm not
going to get ahead because they hate me.
That why he hates me and all that.
He had a real chip on his shoulder about
being black and trying to get ahead and
up,
like willed or whatever.
I wonder if the degree to which they
did not intervene in his is obviously
escalating mental health problems with,
because they were afraid that he was
going to launch some complaints about
racism or something like that.
I wonder if that actually scares people
off from dealing with people just like
they're human beings because they're
afraid of that car getting pulled.
And then getting dragged
into something got off.
Yeah.
Well,
it's almost like we're still responding
to the echoes of the imbalance of the
past that,
you know,
the slavery era echos and the Civil
Rights era echoes of the fifties and
sixties. It's almost like we're
still not even the ship hasn't,
we haven't made it level yet.
You know,
it's almost like that's why this
stuff is, is still tolerated. It's,
it's very confusing to me though when
it's, uh, it's so obvious and so blatant.
Like it wasn't this case.
Um,
it's also very frustrating to me because
as a person who deals with a lot of
martial artists and a lot of people
with the anger issues who have become,
you know, really incredible
members of society and really, uh,
admirable human beings,
people who've learned to harness this,
this frustrated energy that a lot of
young men have with if they grow up and
confused households or whether the
absentee parents or bad neighborhoods or
whatever the factors are that lead them
to be these angry people that can be
channeled and it can be channeled
into a way that develops character.
And it doesn't happen.
So when I see a guy like Trayvon Martin
do what he does and get shot and die and
all this, I see a massive loss of
potential just as a human being,
a young human being, you
know, a young human being,
the commits crimes and does bad things
about 18 he's not even necessarily a bad
person.
What they are more than anything is
just misused potential and misguided.
A human being is so incredibly complex.
There's so many facets and aspects
to being a person and developing as a
productive member of society that it
needs guidance and most people don't get
that guidance and it's up
to them to kind of find it.
I mean, you see an unbelievable tragedy
like that. I always think of like all the,
the terms of the steps and the other
possibilities that might've happened early
intervention,
some teachers somewhere,
some relative or someone who would have
just seen something going off the rails
and really stepped in and made a
difference. I think that title away,
it can be stopped early.
I think once it gains real momentum,
it's tough later on because we
to turning around. But you know,
early intervention, uh, really,
really seeing people who are going off
the rails and then really working to
intervene.
If we could get that down as a society.
And I think we'd live in a different,
well we would,
I would absolutely agree with you.
We would work live in a different
world. But it's, it is very, very,
very difficult to do and incredibly
difficult to pull someone out of that
momentum. The men momentum of
being a bad person and you know,
and almost reveling in it,
you know,
which is a big aspect of gangster rap
or you know, they've, they've done
some really interesting studies where,
cause you know, they just over
the last 10 or 15 years ago,
we see inside the brain, like for the
first time it happened again. This FMRI,
you can really see inside the brain
and they found people who, they've,
who'd been identified a status and they
show them pictures of people being hurt
intentionally and they're like happy joy
centers light up that little like bring
dancers. That's so messed up. You
know, cause it's like opposite,
cause we'll all think we've
got this thing from religion.
Like everyone has a soul and
we're all kind of equal. Oh,
made in the image of God and
this and that and the other.
But it's according to this, people I've
talked to in the research that I've done,
I mean there's some real predators among
us who really are not kind of like us
at all. And it's somebody
who like cs, you know,
some cat being driven over and he
giggles and like finds that really quite
thrilling. I mean that, I didn't
even know what species that it is,
but I think there are a lot of
people out there that they make life.
If I go for the rest of us. Yeah,
it's a real issue. It's very scary.
And how are these people becoming that?
Is it because of nature or nurture?
Is it because of,
you know,
abuse that they've personally
suffered that sort of stimulating?
Yeah. Well so I mean this
is the fascinating thing
about epigenetics, right? So,
I mean, when I was a kid growing up,
there was this nature versus nurture.
Like you got your, if what
you're born with, right?
And then maybe you can
influence it a bit with nature.
But what they're finding out now is
that genes turn on and off depending on
experience.
So they found like if you have a
particular gene and your boy and you are
physically abused as a child, almost
for certain that you're going to end up,
you know, on the bad side of things,
like you're gonna end up violent,
aggressive criminal J or whatever.
Right now if you don't have that gene,
you're abused like you
heard, but it's less. Uh,
and so certain genes for aggression get
turned on and strengthened based upon
your experiences.
You can end up deck twins who grew up
in different households can end up with
different genetics based
on their environment.
So that's what's so important about,
you know, something I focused a lot on,
is it parenting?
Parenting,
parenting seems to be so many people
that are out there and they're just so
messed up.
Like you just,
you can't rewind and you can't
send them down a different path.
But if you kind of look at the next
generation, the next generation,
what if we could have the percentage of
people spanking their children down from
90%.
I mean,
it seems so weird in the 21st century
that that's how parents are really focused
person depending on where you counted, 80
to 90%. It's less so in Europe, like in,
in Sweden,
I think it's been banned since like 1973.
And y'all know what a hell
hole, sweetness, yeah, they're
doing fine. But um, yeah,
it's still 80 to 90%
in, uh, well it's legal.
It's legal in America from two to 12.
You can hit a child in Canada legally,
just not at the face and not with
an implement. Um, so it's just,
and cause these are the most vulnerable,
tender, helpless, dependent, you know,
lack of freedom, members of
society. And uh, but it's, you know,
it's hard to see how our
weird society that we have.
You had this great bit last night. Go
see the show. Anyone has listened to.
This is my show.
We did this great bit like what a space
aliens come down and try and understand.
You had Kim kind of ask you in which
of course is tough enough, but,
but what if they tried to understand that
culture? It wouldn't make much sense,
but you realize that the hierarchies and
everything that we have there, the wars,
the prisons, prisons, the prison
guards from wards, you need soldiers,
you can't get healthy,
happy,
well adjusted people to go
out and do that kind of stuff.
So I think our whole society relies
upon the maltreatment of children.
And if we didn't have that,
a lot of people that got a lot of money
and power right now would kind of find
themselves out in the cold.
Yeah.
I don't necessarily think
that it's engineered that way,
but I certainly think it takes
advantage of the situation at hand.
I don't think there's a secret cabal,
secret handshake, but you know,
lions get together to hand else.
They don't have to plot it
out in some smokey romance.
It's just their instincts
to go get the guns.
That does get sort of a
hypothesized though, right?
The that that is what's happening,
that they're trying to keep people
down with a lack of education.
That's why there's such little funding
for schools and they're trying to keep
people poor because poor people don't
raise their kids correctly and you know,
and so on and so forth,
and then it continues.
I think we have an instinct for domination
as human beings and I think animals
do too,
and they don't have secret cabals and
Rockefellers and smoky rooms organizing
everything.
I think we just have an instinct for
domination and it plays itself out,
but I don't think it's something written
down and handed out in the secret and
rails scrolls or something like that.
I agree with you. I think we also have
an instinct for escalation, you know,
and no matter what, we always want
more, you know, if we make $500 a week,
we want seven. If we, if we
control middle of the Middle East,
we want to control Africa,
we want to, it's just,
it's a natural thing that
if we do a certain thing,
we will continue to do it and try to push
the envelope further and further until
we hit some sort of a wall or resistance.
But I think in America we are starting
to see that wall built up and,
and gain momentum.
The wall of resistance against the Syria.
A invasion was bigger than anything
that I'd ever seen in my entire life.
I'd never seen a university across the
the entire country go, fuck this. Yeah,
this is crazy.
You're not, this might be the first
war. It's actually stopped. Yeah.
Like in history,
so you'd be the first war that popular
was an resistance has actually stopped
against all the financial,
military,
industrial complex momentum that is
in the states, which is huge. Right?
I don't know if you know the fact that
the people who vote voted Yes for the war
in Syria get 86% more funding for the
military industrial complex and the people
who voted, now that's just voting to
send money in blood to the donors, right?
I mean it's horrible. Uh,
but, but the half that it
might actually be pushed back.
And the fact that the Russian guy that
Putin is telling the recipient of the
Nobel peace prize to not have a war,
it's upside down universe that we live in.
And you know, and not only that, but Putin
said a really interesting thing about,
about claiming that citizens of the
United States are exceptional and how
dangerous that is and about how
we are all just human beings.
And to have anybody established as
being the exceptional people is a very
dangerous idea.
And for the United States to sort of
promote this idea that we as Americans are
different. Like, yeah, that's,
that's, he's absolutely right.
If an individual displays
that characteristics,
they're called entitled or narcissistic,
which means that just good things
come should come to me no matter what.
And if they don't, they're not brought
to me, I'm just going to go take them.
And that's a really
dangerous personality trait.
But somehow it's elevated through the
magic of patriotism until like wonderful
stuff. Right? Yeah, that's fine.
It's fascinating. I
mean, and as I get older,
I find it even more fascinating because
a guy like Obama, I'm 46 the guy, look,
Obama is just a couple
of years older than me.
So it's not like this thing where when
I was a boy and I would look at the
resident, yeah, they were way
up there. There were different
then, you know, it was,
there were always a part of this
system already. Political System,
educational system, skull
and bones, all that.
But this Obama guy was the first guy
that doesn't fit that mold to me.
And it's close to my age. And you know,
the concept of me being a president,
it was just the most ridiculous
thing of all time to me.
But this guy is essentially my,
obviously more educated than me,
but essentially my age.
And I find it amazing how he has gone
from being this political outsider,
this rebel, this guy who was going to
change this closed Guantanamo Bay and,
and then all of a sudden he gets in and
he's exactly the same thing that we've
seen time and time again over
the last eight years. It's easy.
The same person as Bush. I mean it's,
and more and more, more drone. Yeah.
More detainees. Uh, and, and the
only reason he ended the war in Iraq,
it was quite fascinating and tragic, you
know, if you have hope for the guy, right.
The reason that they had to pull the
troops out of Iraq was that Iraq was,
was going to start holding the troops
criminally responsible for what they were
doing because they were facing such
resistance from the population for the
occupation. They finally said, okay,
you guys don't get to get out
of jail free card anymore.
We're going to start applying
international military or military law.
Your and Obama's like, okay,
fire up there, the airplanes,
we're going to pull those buggers out
because they're going to be subject to the
rule of law.
And they had to get him out of there.
Well, how about what he
wrote on his own website,
the change.org website
about whistleblowers and
then removed it, you know,
after it would was, he was called out
on it after the Edward Snowden case,
like they said like what did
you say about whistleblowers?
What did you say about whistler?
Blows were exposing illegal activities
when you were running for president and
now here you are the most
as far as presidents go.
There's never been a president that
has been harder on whistle blowers then
Obama never,
nor have there been more revelations
and more important revelations as far as
the direction of society and privacy in
the United States that was exposed by
these whistle blowers.
That has a massive impact on our culture.
Massive impact on who has the right.
Do you,
do I have a right to send a naked photo
to a friend as a joke or is that going
to be held against me? You know, if, uh,
I don't pay my taxes or if, you know,
I have a dispute with the
government over a certain issue.
Are you going to pull things out of emails
because they have someone writes bomb
and an email, you know, as a
joke. Does that get flagged and,
and just a comedian, that's a word you
may well use. Yeah. Yeah. I mean not now.
I defragged I don't know what you're
going to call it now and kind of use that
word anymore.
Yeah, I mean, but there's a lot
of hot words and to me that's,
that's a dangerous thing to I think what
we're in right now as far as the whole
privacy thing is this
strange transitionary period
to a point where I think
ultimately there will be no privacy.
And I think,
I don't think that's bad because look,
we were all really cool and everyone
was really nice to each other.
Privacy wouldn't be as as important.
It becomes important when people
violate privacy and there's stalkers and
there's,
you know,
people that fuck with people and people
that you know or have agendas to mess
with people's lives.
But ultimately privacy,
what we're dealing with,
inflammation and the trend in society
and technology seems to be the dissolving
of boundaries between people.
And information.
And I think it's been amazing as far as
education. When you look at your phone,
you can Google something, you get have
answers to any question. I mean this is,
we live in an amazing time when it
comes to that, but that trend, you know,
we've talked about escalation.
It's just what we do.
We're getting that trend will escalate
further and further and I think
ultimately it will escalate to the
point where they'll be no more secrets.
Yeah. I mean I, I mean the technology
that we were having this conversation,
we can broadcast it to like millions
of people and I got like 50 million
downloads of my shell, which for a
philosophy show is incredible easy. Right?
But this is huge,
right?
So it's like these two bullet trains
going across the landscape, right?
And the technology of control versus
the technology of illumination.
I think it really, really battling
and we got to keep pushing the gas to,
to stay ahead because we've got this
incredible thing. Uh, you mentioned it,
the end, the show recently, like
the gatekeepers are down, right?
If we get half this compensation,
broadcast it directly to people,
nobody has to tell us
what we can talk about.
Nobody tells us what words we can
use or what concepts we can explore,
anything like that,
which is unprecedented except maybe
for the Gutenberg press and like 15th
Century.
When they printed the Bible and started
handing it out to passes in a language
they could actually understand.
Because before that you had to know
Latin and all that kind of crap.
So they got to read the Bible for
the first time and like, Oh shit,
I'm getting me. This is
in here. This is in here.
They started to develop their own
thoughts about it and that broke down the
monopoly of the Catholic
Christian did mine,
which had been around since the dark ages.
So when you get information to people,
you fragment the central narrative of a
society, which is great. You know, that's,
that's what you want. Central Narratives
are incredibly dangerous. You know,
we had a great central narratives,
the Nazis that wonderful
central narratives about the
role of the white race to
dominate all the other races in
Germany's manifest destiny and Europe.
Communist had a great story
about that are, you know,
raising the proletariat destruction of
the middle classes and the end of the
bourgeoisie narratives that are really
well inflicted and universal are
incredibly dangerous.
So all the lemmings we're on the same way.
So we've got this massive airstrike on
a central narrative which comes directly
out of this technology,
which is where you can get exposed to
viewpoints that you never would've been
exposed to before.
If you think before the Internet and
American media would be playing anything
that Vladimir Putin said about Syria,
you'd never even know the guy
said anything and totally road.
Now you can get it all and
you can connect with people.
I want to talk about that.
The comedy stuff where I think the
connection stuff is really a good theme in
the show last night,
but there's rice because the degree
to which we can shatter the central
narrative and individualize what
we're doing in the world is, you know,
they're racing with us to try and control
and make us afraid to communicate with
each other and afraid to get to the
truth and I really view that as pretty
important razor for
like the next 10 years.
Yeah, I agree. I think there's,
the real issue in this world
is a information and then
of course the big one is
the monopolization of resources and
the monopolization of resources,
which are I believe,
I think resources should be in
global asset for human beings.
I don't think anybody should be
able to control the amount of oil,
just like I don't think people
should be able to control water.
I think it's ridiculous.
The idea that a group of human
beings decided to control water.
I feel like that that's an act almost
of terrorism, of social terrorism.
The idea of keeping water from
people that need water. You know,
the idea of keeping oil from people.
I mean if we all agree that
we're going to use oil,
the idea that one person can decide,
you know,
who owns the shift that has been in
the ground for millions and millions of
years just because you planted a flag on
a patch of dirt. It's fucking craziness.
But that's where all the
influence comes from.
The influence comes from this massive
amount of money that you can gain by
controlling monopolize
and natural resources.
And it's just like when they used to be
able to monopolize the information that
was received.
Just like when William Randolph Hearst
basically controlled most of what
information got out to people,
read newspapers,
that that's a dangerous aspect
of our world. That is eventually,
I think going to crumble under
the weight of its own bullshit.
I just don't see how it can continue.
I don't see how people can continue to
live the way we're living right now in
the face of the information
that we're being presented with.
Well, you know, the great thing is
once you go outside and narrative,
don't you finding? For me, I feel
pretty retarded most of the time.
Like I'm not dumb guy, but I see so much
information out there. So many things,
so many stories. I can do all this
research for my shows and stuff like that.
I feel like it barely
scratched the surface because
there's so much information
about there. With the central narrative,
you feel like, you know, well, you know,
we were Catholic so we're Jews or we're
Jesuit. So we got, we got it down,
we got the whole thing down.
Right?
But the great thing is once you
shattered that central narrative,
you realize there's such a vast amount
of conflicting information and opinions
and perspectives and I don't know what
the hell is true half the time, you know,
I'm lucky to get 10% of it.
So I think that that breeds a kind of
humility in us that that is the opposite
of the desire to dominate. The
desire to dominate is, well,
I know what the hell people should do,
and by God I'm going to make them do it.
I know they shouldn't smoke marijuana,
and if they fucking smoke marijuana,
I'm going to round them up with cats
in blue uniforms and throw them in that
prison cell. You know, where 200,000
times a year they get raped. I mean,
an American, more men get raped
and women don't get it of habits.
The whole prison stuff, right? Yeah.
So when you feel like you just know how
the health everyone else should live,
you know,
the way we should help the poor is
take money from these guides by force,
give it to a giant bureaucracy and have
a little drops of it ripped down to the
poor.
Have to keep them in it dependent state
so they'll keep voting for more and more
government.
If you've really feel like
you know exactly how people
should live in what they
should do,
then you have no problem bringing out
the air strikes at the military and the
police and the prison system.
But if you're humble and you realize
that we're pretty much retarded and had
everything, there's a few things that
I'm good at, but most of it, you know,
I'm not going to draw my own
teeth and I do my own appendix.
I barely even clean my own house.
Right.
But once you get exposed to a vast
amount of contradictory information,
you realize just like we're all kind
of stupid and that's why we should be
humble and not order each other
around at the point of a gun,
which was so addicted to doing these days.
Transplant out a great quote about that,
about the bonfire of enlightenment,
the one the, as the bonfire of
enlightenment grows brighter,
the surface area of ignorance becomes
more illuminated and you realize the more
you learn, the more there is to
learn and then it becomes impossible.
Well, human knowledge doubles
every 18 months these days.
Like there's just no possibility that
anyone can be anywhere close to mastering
any, any significant. Yeah.
Well that's great though.
I think that's great because
I think there's a real
danger in claiming, you know,
and, and Clinton, that kind of
arrogance that comes from, uh,
especially very highly educated people
in specific areas of you very highly
educated in a specific area.
They oftentimes are arrogant about things
that they're ignorant about. And it's,
it's interesting to watch
that become an impossibility.
You're faced with such a massive
amount of data that's just online.
I'm like Twitter every day.
I'm exposed to dozens and dozens of
fascinating stories a
week or two in each one.
We, because we've got to, if we've got to
go up and make a buck or whatever, right?
But just love to dig into all this stuff.
And I'd love to learn
every language there is.
And I'd love to know every song
that was. Yeah, but you can't
at least a small grasp of what the
fuck they're talking about when they're
talking about quantum physics.
That's never gonna happen.
I think once you understand
quantum physics, it changes on it.
It's one of those things. Grab
fog. Fireman's quote was it?
If you think you understand quantum
physics and quantum physics, I,
I've read so many articles on it.
I don't know what
right it to someone,
they'll say this is the amazing
thing that just came out today,
but I don't know what it means.
Change at some geometric object that
explains the interactions of particles.
As long as my shoes,
them attending distracts that he'd
my feet because of some quantum flux.
I'm okay with it. I know it does
some creepy shit. Deep down.
I know that also read like by the time
it comes to the level of your sense like
it all cancels out and you, you know, this
is still going to be a table tomorrow,
but deep down in the roots of matters,
some really crazy shit is going on.
Yeah. Subatomic partners, apartments
blinking in and out of existence,
existing simultaneously,
two different places in motion and
still at the same time like what are you
talking to me?
We basically,
what they're saying is that the heart
of matter itself, the, the, the,
the smallest measurable
portion of reality is magic.
I mean that's really, you
know, you're going to get
emails from physicists saying,
Oh, don't call it magic. It's not
magic. It's just the little confusing.
Thank you for correcting me and all.
I had magic to us.
But then these microphones
are kind of magic to me.
These little magic penises that record
everything we say. It's amazing.
I had Dr Amit Goswami on my podcast who's
one of the great quantum physicist of
our age who is just impossible
to understand. It mean it just,
he would just go,
it's gone so far into the bushes.
It's talking magic. And I mean
it's just, it's so strange.
But that is the accepted smallest
measurable part of the universe.
And it's amazing when you really started
to think about what we know about
nature and nature of being
fractal in so many different ways.
The universe itself being fractal.
And then when you get down to the
smallest measurable components of,
of reality itself being this
strange fiction almost world,
it's so bizarre. It's impossible to
know everything. So I think this,
this, this age of enlightenment that we're
in right now is really unprecedented.
I don't think there's ever been a time
like this and once you break down the
narrative,
right?
So I mean my boring education's all the
history of philosophy and science and
you know, in the, in the, um,
the renaissance and the
enlightenment is when people said,
well God doesn't answer anything.
You know,
God is a barrier to [inaudible]
cause as long would you say God did.
It's like all right, we've
got an answer. I did it.
And then it becomes something that's
blasphemous, did the question.
And so when people began
to doubt the God thing,
then they began to be able to explore,
right? They began to say, okay,
well if God didn't do it, what the
hell did we get here? You know, what
is the world and what does the sun,
how does it work in all that?
I think we kind of get in there and
in a really painful, difficult way.
I think we're kind of getting there cause
we've knocked this narrative and it's
like in the future,
I guarantee you it's going
to be completely insane to
look back and say people
ever believe the shit. I mean, you know,
the guys who kept their own balls off
to go join that comment, you know,
you look back and just say it wasn't,
wasn't there. So someone said, you know,
when you're bringing out the pink and
sheers and taken off your tidy whities,
there's gotta be someone who's saying,
we were kind of going in
the wrong direction here.
But I think in the future I look
back at us like that and say,
what were they thinking?
Like we have these geographical areas
called countries and in those countries we
have a tiny group of people with all
the guns in the world and they tell
everyone else wanted to do. And somehow
we think this is going to work out fine.
I can't believe I wasn't recording.
I wasn't recording up until just now.
Luckily I have to get the first, whatever,
27 minutes. We got it. There we go.
Folks who are listening to this will, will
normalize this years are the meatiest,
but the voice quality goes,
I'm considering, I suck
at technology. I'm sorry,
I can't believe that this
wasn't recording. But, uh,
again, Trayvon Martin, quantum physics.
Well, you know, that, that's where
we saw everything. We saw 27 minutes,
we had the whole fucking thing down.
Well, I'll, I'll, I'll make sure it gets
normalized. Um, but the, you know, the,
the, the, the, I think that the enormity
of the times we live in really, it's,
it's really easy for us
to not notice it or not.
It's so normal to just be able to
call some money on your cell phone.
So normal to able to get on the
Internet and just get information.
I think the enormity of
this as far as what is that,
what that's like in comparison
to having to go to the library,
into getting your education from a
school which you're getting, you know,
if you're taking science,
you're getting it from this professor
and this professor is going to remote
recommend these books and there may be
a completely opposing point of view that
you're never going to be exposed to.
Whereas if you Google something, you know,
and then Google that sprays and then
do bunked. Yeah. Know, man, I have,
I can't tell you how many fucking times
I've had someone send me something and
then I'll say Google when you just sent
me and then debunked and then was talk
and if you haven't read that stuff,
got to talk to me.
Cause if you're only getting one side,
it's not any side at all.
Yeah, you're not, you're getting
this weird sort of confirmation bias,
see thing that exists.
What I've heard that argument as to
why the Internet is bad, that one,
one of the bad things about the internet
is you seek out like minded people and
you sort of confirm each other's
biases and get together and you know,
pat each other on the back sort of.
Yes.
But I feel like those are
just little camps, you know,
outside of the Wilderness of information,
which is New York City, you know,
like get my,
you might have a tent where all you
assholes get together and said that the
earth is 6,000 years old. Right.
But you know, you're, you're, uh,
an hour's walk from Manhattan,
right? You're not gonna,
you're not gonna survive.
Well,
I don't remember all
those people talking about a unity of
narrative and seeking out like minded
people really complaining about say the
Church that I grew up in or the public
school that I grew up in, Brian
was taught that, you know,
governments are necessary
beneficial, wonderful. And you know,
we fought the Second World War to defend
against national socialism and we won.
And like we had,
we already had that narrative.
Now people are fragmenting
into their own narratives,
but that's still way better than one
monolithic nonsense pile that we're all
supposed to in mind.
Right?
Yes. Yeah, I am. It's also
like as a human being,
what we have been given is this insane
amount of potential in the mind and in
the body's ability to
manipulate matter in nature.
But yet we don't have a real direction
book and we're sort of figuring out the
abilities of this mind and
the possibilities of, of,
of society and our interactions with
each other and the accumulation of
information that we can all rely on
each different aspect of our culture to
contribute. Whether it's, you know, a
history or science or mathematics or,
and all this stuff comes together and the
potential of it as almost unfathomable.
It's almost impossible to really truly
wrap our heads around and we only figure
out how to do things.
You write by trial and error,
we have to fuck up and then go,
well, we can't do that again.
And we have to drop a nuclear bomb and go,
well that's a disaster. And we have to,
you know, it's, we have this
incredible device, the human mind,
and we have very little idea of how to
utilize it properly or even less control
or engineer engineered thought into
how to develop people properly and,
and to,
to try to enforce that as a culture
or to recommend that or try to just,
I mean,
when you see the president on television,
what are they always deal with the
leader of the free world? Well,
they deal with conflict.
They're constantly dealing with conflict
and loss and finances and they're
dealing with all these things that are
important to people that are developed
and how much thought is actually given
to developing people. How much thought,
I mean,
how,
what does the last time you heard the
president United States talk about what we
really need to do is focus on the lowest
rung of our ladder with the weakest
link in our chain of human
beings and strengthen that.
Wouldn't we be a better country if we
had less losers, wouldn't we? I mean,
isn't that something we should concentrate
on, but it never gets brought up.
There's never talk about enriching poor
neighborhoods or setting up community
centers,
finding ways to help young
children that don't have guidance,
brilliant people and have fucking
companies like Halliburton funded.
You want to make a lot of money
rebuild Detroit, you know, fuck Iraq,
rebuild Detroit, fuck going to countries
and blowing them up and rebuilding them.
Concentrate on what's already fucked up
right here and it's never done. And it's,
it's, we, we, we look at it in terms of,
you know,
it's almost like going from going from
presidential run to presidential runs,
like these four year terms
that they do in a, in a way,
it's almost like the idea of having a
president and having these small four year
terms, it's like you're always
going to concentrate on what,
just problems as far as like
conflict and money here,
he's going to concentrate on what's on
the tip of people's tongues all the time,
but not on the engineering of society.
Yeah. It's, it's all here.
No prevention. Yes. Right.
So I'll just play whack a
mole with whatever fucking
crisis is coming up at the
moment and it's not how are we going to
make it so that society can be seen in
40 years.
They don't care about any of that stuff.
I mean that's why there's a national debt.
That's why this war,
because it's just about getting elected.
Like the of the Federal Reserve just said,
well we're going to keep buying
$85 billion worth of us treasuries.
Even though we said we were going to
stop because there's going to be an
election coming up. And what do they
care if they pass the bill to the unborn?
I mean they've gotta to be long gone.
So we have this weird society that
this these really narrow time slices,
which is just all about,
you know,
whack a mole and satisfying the noisiest
people and keeping those people too.
But the actual work of preventing
in the long run, which is so easy,
the science is so easy. It's so simple.
You know, reason with your children.
Don't hit your children's do treat them
like they're reasonable human beings.
I mean,
I'm a dad of them.
I've been a stay at home dad
for like four and a half years.
Never had to raise my voice and my
daughter never had to yell at her,
never had to hit her,
never had to have a timeout.
We just reason things through that gets
not doing that about 18 months of age to
studies show that can stop the
reason they can start to negotiate.
And if we had that,
if we had that as a society,
I can virtually guarantee you there
would be almost no criminality.
I agree,
but don't you think that
there's an economic aspect
of that that really can't be
norm? You have the ability to
do that and very few people do.
That's the real issue is
that so many people do.
You have a working mom and
a working dad and the kids,
by the time they see their parents,
they mean they're ready to go to bed.
I mean it's four or five o'clock at
night if they're lucky, you know,
most of the time they see their parents
afterwards. So it's six, seven, you know,
and they've been in there since eight
o'clock in the morning and they're
exhausted and everyone, they
got to feed them, bathe them.
They don't really have time for quality
interaction. It's very different
called the idea that
people have been sold,
that you can raise a child and have
a full career. I think it's madness.
It's kind of do it. You can't do it. Yeah.
And this idea that daycare just kind of
use you put him in daycare and that's
fine. Um, it's just not true. I mean,
statistically for actually scientifically
there kids who are in daycare from
other 20 hours a week experience exactly
the same symptoms as those who have
been abandoned by their mothers.
Like it's, it's the experience,
maternal abandonment at a very fundamental
level of changes their neurological
system.
It changes their stress responses to
changes that cortisol levels permanent,
that you measure it 10, 20 years
later. It's still the same.
So this idea that you can just
march, people have to work, hey,
it's great for the government.
I mean,
government loves it when both parents
work because then they got to taxes to tax
basis to tax capital out there,
spending money into the treasury.
Plus then they got to
put the kid in daycare.
So then there's somebody else who they
can tax, who's taking care of the kids.
So the government loves
it really. Absolutely. GDP
because everyone's working,
they get much more taxes and the
problems of having kids in daycare, well,
they get shuffled down to
the next generation and who
the hell do you know it's
about that gets done vote, right? Yeah.
But what's the solution to that? I mean,
it's going to be so difficult as a vice
sacrifice, you know? I mean, I mean,
people got a war,
you know what I mean?
Millions and millions of people went to
war in the Second World War in the first
world war. I mean marching into
hailstorms and bullets and,
and typhus and all that, going to
horrible stuff that went on. You know,
where we say to people, I say to people
all the time, you know, you know,
if you went to college,
you know you live like a dog.
He most people live like dogs when they
go to college for four years because it
was a good investment. Well, take that
same approach. If you want to have kids,
you don't both have to work, just
downsize, get rid of the second car.
Just we're not asking you to go
fight the Japanese, you know,
in some godforsaken island in the Pacific.
And it was just maybe
move to a smaller house,
moved to an apartment just a couple
of years when the kids, you know,
kids personalities, 90% done by
the time they're four, you know,
so all you got to do the first
couple of years, just sacrifice.
Have someone at home, breastfeed
your child, look at and say,
cause that's what nature
intended and sacrifice. You know?
So maybe you don't get the big screen TV,
but you will know what you get is like
a happy child throughout your life
and you get to develop a human being
in the correct way. Yeah, it's,
it's so easy for us to say, you
know, my wife is a stay at home wife,
stay at home mom and uh, you know,
we have three children and you know,
we're very fortunate and
everything works out great,
but I'm in a unique financial
situation that can happen.
Whereas I have a lot of friends
that are not in that situation.
They're trying to raise children and
they're also trying to put them in daycare
during the day.
And you know,
the wife just went back to work because
we have bills and this and that and you
see it and it's, it's not, it's not
the way a child wants to develop.
It doesn't seem healthy. No.
I mean historically, you know,
you put your kid in the backpack,
he went out and worked in the fields,
you go hunting, you bring your kid. I
mean, that's, they're supposed to be,
it's so weird,
the 21st century to say
children's supposed to be
with their parents and I'm a,
how would we ever drifted away that,
that even needs to be said, you know,
what do you think that is? Do
you think that's a, just a,
a desire from materialism and
some sort of a rationalization
that you can, uh, you can go after both,
that you can acquire all these things and
keep up with the Joneses and just have
someone else take care of the busy work
of taking care of your child when you do
that?
Is that what it is?
Yeah, I think, I think what happened was,
and this would have happened in the
sixties and seventies I sweat in the 50s
this whole amazing series of
labor saving devices came out,
which freed women from the drudgery of
dishwashers came out and laundry machines
and vacuum cleaners and all
that kind of stuff. Right?
So basically a huge amount of work
was done by machines now, which,
which freed up women. Then of course
a lot of them were like, okay, great,
I'm gonna go work for us or whatever.
But I think what's really
been downgraded is,
is the skills required to
be a good parent. I mean,
I've done some tough stuff in
life. I've built, built businesses.
I started this crazy show and all
that kind of stuff. Nothing. To me,
it's more exciting and challenging
than being a dad. I mean,
I know it's a cliche and it was
all it said was wonderful things,
but it really is an
incredible thing to do,
especially if you don't do
any of the aggression stuff.
Cause then you got to come up with
that other stuff. Right. Other ways of,
of dealing with conflicts, other ways
of dealing with quote bad behavior.
It's really challenging now if you just
spank and your kids and yelling at them,
I guess it's not that challenging
and hell of a lot. Not Fine. Right?
Because all you're doing is spending
your whole day trying to control someone
who doesn't want to be controlled.
That's not fun.
So I think that because we've got this
head Aman and put them in timeouts and
send them to bed without dinner
and yell at them or whatever.
I mean that's retarded. Anyone
could do that. You know,
you can get an angry robot to do that.
Right? But if you don't do that stuff,
then you have a really unique challenge
of negotiating with someone who's three.
I mean, how exciting is that? What
an incredible challenge that is.
But because we've still got the hitting
and the yelling and all of that,
it's retired. And so people say,
well, this is stupid and not fun,
so I'm going to go to work,
but it's only stupid or not fun
because you're yelling and hitting.
If you didn't do that and
it would be really engaged
it. And it's the most important
aspect of our society.
The most important aspect of our family
is the most important aspect of our
communities is developing
good human beings.
And it's one that we leave to everybody.
We'll just go work.
I know you fucked your whole life up,
but uh,
take care of this person and that person
will in turn transfer everything that
you've taught them and that any way that
you fucked them up or made them better
and they're going to go out into
the world and spread that energy.
And it literally changes the tone
of our entire society and culture.
And it's fascinating when
you see different cultures
all throughout the world.
If you study the, the, the different
ways they interact with their children,
how vastly different the,
the culture itself becomes because of
these styles of interaction and our
culture, which is thought to be
universally one of the most materialistic,
selfish child blood cultures is one of
the cultures that embraces this idea of
the, the two parents working the
childcare, the, you know, this,
this,
this idea of how we've decided to promote
becoming a human being is one of the
most awkward,
weird examples of it on earth.
Could you imagine, could you imagine
it's your anniversary, but ended,
you got married a couple
of years ago. You'd be with
your wife a long time, right?
Imagine it's your anniversary and she
calls you up and she says, Joe, you know,
it's our anniversary that
for a nice dinner. I got
babysitter and you say, Oh man,
I can't believe what a cliche. I
completely forgot. So sorry. Oh my God,
that's so embarrassing.
But I'll tell you what I'll do.
I'll call up someone we don't know and
I'm going to pay them minimum wage to go
out for dinner with you. Now they may not
speak great English, you know they mean,
I mean they've never met you before,
but I'm sure it's going to be pretty much
the same as going out for dinner with
me,
your ever loving husband.
So let me just make that
call to the agency to send
out some half broken English
speaking guy to go out for dinner with
you and it's going to be exactly the same.
She'd be like, no, it's not the same
because you don't, my husband is some guy,
I don't even know, but why the hell would
we think parenting is any different?
I mean how the hell you
replace the bond of,
of the new grew the bang and challenging
New Valley and you breastfeed the child
and you know that child.
But I'm sure some minimum wage stranger
who's rotating in and out of a job every
four months is going to be exactly the
same as a parent. It's not the same.
And the consequences to society
a significant, and it's,
it's very frustrating to me
when I communicate with him.
People that are,
especially women that are single,
that are thinking about having
a child on her own. Uh, I've,
I've had so many as I could and I get it.
I get that they want a child and I get
that they want a child and that they
can't find a man.
I understand that it's hard to find
someone that you compatible with,
but God damn is that a terrible idea?
It works sometimes.
Sometimes it works.
Sometimes you get lucky and you meet
someone and somewhere along the line
some people fall out of the building.
And the way that doesn't mean that that
should be your next step engineered.
It's engineered that way. Those God
such a disaster statistically. Right?
I mean statistically and factually
there's no single worst predictor for kids
outcome then being from a
single mom household. You know,
and I hate to say it cause I mean again,
there's lots of single moms out there
really trying to do the right thing.
Some single moms like how he got hit
by a truck terror, you know, and they,
you know, all the support, all the, you
know, but the vast majority of it is,
you know, it didn't find the man
or just ditch the man or whatever.
And it is catastrophic for kids.
I mean the statistics are horrendous.
Like 80% of rapists come from
single parent households.
85% of murderers. I mean,
not again,
not that they all turned out that way,
but when you see these
significantly negative elements,
a lot of it gets traced back.
This is theory that says that is
kind of working this out fairly well.
They say that, um, if marriage rates
have stayed at the 1970 levels,
right, cause you know, marriage
rates are really low these days. Um,
and marriage not necessarily the same as,
you know,
two people committing to say
to get the mother, raise a kid,
but we would have almost no deficit in
government spending of marriage rates and
stayed as they did in 1970.
You know, when the majority,
vast majority of us got married,
stay married and so on.
Because marital disintegration, I mean,
getting a huge rise in welfare state,
huge and criminality costs huge rise in,
in uh,
every everything you can
think of in society that if
you trace back the deficit,
a lot of it has to do with this, this
breakdown of the family, which is,
I mean some people say it's
all engineered and Abi,
I don't credit the ruling class with
that much. Deviousness. Uh, but um,
I don't even know. So I did. It is,
it is something that is really
has to be talked about. I mean,
particularly for boys, I mean boys these
days are having a real rough, you know,
like the schools are really focused on,
on girls and how girls learn and
you know, boys, yeah. Oh yeah.
There's the huge change has been
a boys like to learn hands on.
They like to learn viscerally.
They don't like to just sit
there and read about stuff.
We'll see the teacher do stuff on
blackboards. And about 30 years ago,
a bunch of feminists said,
well,
girls are getting shortchanged in
school and it's all designed for boys.
And it's really shifted the curriculum.
And since then or has it been
just falling behind catastrophic?
Like so 60% of like, uh,
people in, in university does
and our girls and you know,
I think it's like nine times the number
of voids around these psycho tropic
brain killing meds are because they just,
the boys don't want to sit still all day,
but the society views girls as great
and boys is like broken girls. You know,
if we could just get them to be like
the girls and sit quietly and you know,
with their legs crossed and
all that. Uh, but why boys?
It just getting a real reference
school these days. And again,
because they're growing up without dads,
they don't have that role model of how
to channel that aggression. And so,
you know,
it's real rough and this is why they
just get medicated so rapidly and then it
escalates. You talked about
escalation escalates from there.
You get one drug for Adhd
and then you can't sleep.
So you get another drug for that and then
you start developing bipolar symptoms,
you get another drug for that.
And that all went down.
I think he's getting so kind of you get
another drag for that next thing you
know, living in a facility for the
rest of your life. It's masters
and that's a huge issue in the society.
The amount of money and the amount
of influence that pharmaceutical drug
companies have a our society, the fact
that this money is something that they,
they count on.
This is money that has been coming in
and once you have a corporation that's
used to acquiring wealth
or we have a bottom line,
this is what we make and why we're
making less now, why would it be no,
they're not going to step in and say,
listen, I think we be better for society,
society so that we earn
less money smoking crater.
But that CEO is and someone else
has to be is going to do that.
Whether you talked about
this in the show yesterday,
guess a gator roll oh data role. When
you're a gator grabs a hold of its prey.
They roll.
But yeah,
I'm not going to a big clarity cause you
gotta see this and I gotta tell you I
was haunted by that when I drive.
I like the idea of you spinning around.
It's like, oh my God, there's
not enough in the world.
We see them alligator bite
on to a, yeah, they spin,
they were seeing and they try and rip
it out of the joint down on the side or
something.
That's how the Ted is not helping my
mental image to think of your mental image
with an alligator next.
That's this whole kind of people who don't
know my job or like what the fuck are
they talking about? But go see it
because it's worth breaking it. But,
but you had to scrape it
when you're talking, talking
about like it's pharmaceutical companies.
Well you know,
try masturbating and
with pot and stay awake.
But I think that's something else
too, which is that, you know,
why is tobacco legal and part is
not? Well, as it never discussed,
it just kills 5,000 people in there.
And because tobacco is a factory farm
product part, you can grow at home, right?
So if you enable people to self medicate,
you know,
and I don't mean that in a bad
way, but to self medicated, right?
Like you having trouble sleeping,
I smoke a bit of part and you fall asleep,
right? You can grow that shit
at home, in your basement,
in your backyard or whatever.
There's no profit to anyone.
So that stuff like the
stuff you can grow tobacco,
you can't grow tobacco in your backyard.
Will you be affected for tobacco?
You wouldn't have to have a license
to do so. Right, right, right.
It's not like you can grow
tomatoes,
like you can grow your own tomatoes,
but when you deal with anything
that affects your consciousness,
you have to have, uh, uh, you know,
the government has to step
in and allow you to do so,
which is we can just make your own ooze.
Oh, right, right. Your own moonshine.
Isn't it elite? I mean, this has
got to be some sort of regulations.
It's like you can, you craft beer
making, right? But how does that work?
Do you have to?
Well I think as long as you don't sell it,
I mean I think you can make your
own stuff at home or whatever,
but I think that tobacco, you
need like a big, you know,
certain only certain places and a big
crop and stuff like that and process that
you just really hyper as pot use grow,
it's not.
So I think it would be really tough,
you know,
cause we measure economic
productivity this weird way, you know,
like if someone gets sick that GDP
goes up. Like how is that same?
I mean surely it's sickness,
it's a bad thing that you shouldn't
reflect a negative result. But you know,
they go spend a lot of money on
treatments and suddenly he's like woo,
we're richer. You know?
And, and so same thing,
if you then have people smoking
pot but they ground themselves,
your GDP is going to take a huge crater.
And then all these people that
are going to be out of work,
who's supplying all this horrible
stuff to people and so on. And I mean,
the way we measure stuff now,
I mean it's just completely as
forces everyone into these really,
really bad decisions.
Yeah.
I wonder,
one of the things he said that I really
agree with about how boys are so much
different than girls, uh,
when it comes to learning.
I just recently started volunteering
at my daughter's school and she's in
kindergarten and I watch boys.
Do you volunteer like these?
They have these tables
set up and you have to,
everyone has to put together this little
book and cut these pieces out and put
it in order and you watch boys do it
as opposed to girls and they're sturdy.
They're a different animal.
I mean it's a completely different thing.
They are almost like they're there.
They're so challenged like the
girls can just do, do, do, do,
do it nicely and humming
to themselves and attend.
These aren't the hunting and the lines
and that they're barely paying attention
to what's going on. They want to run, they
want to go do something. And it's like,
that's how I felt growing up.
I always felt like,
I can't wait for this fucking bell rang
so I can run outta here. Yeah. And it,
I thought at the time,
well obviously I'm not very smart and
I'm not going to be good at school and it
wasn't that at all. But what it
was was I am not designed for this.
Like there is a society and this society
has a broad spectrum of human beings
and we have various tasks that we will
do and we will be really good at and
we'll have different occupations that
we can choose and different one suit,
different personalities,
but this fucking cookie cutter
shit that they do in school,
they want everyone to be the same way
because that's all they have money for.
That's all we have resources for.
We have,
we have the ability to stick you in
this class from 9:00 AM to whatever,
2:00 PM and do this stuff
and then you know, we,
we need you to listen and then you go
and then you leave and we'll give you a
grade on it. And it's madness. The idea
of that as an educational backbone, that,
that, that has an educational foundation
for a human being. It's madness. No
nothing to give to their
history. You know, there's,
there's two things that are best, the
best predictors of empathy, right?
Empathy is what we really,
really need as a species.
Like we're fucked with that empathy
because we've got these weapons of mass
destruction,
we got to do your weapons and we go like
if we don't really work on empathy is
the most important resource.
So the question is how do you grow it?
Two things seem to Kim come up on the top
of the list for how to grow up empathy.
Uh, I would never have guessed them,
so I'm like, let's get a driver.
And the two things that,
that rice at the top,
when it comes to developing empathy,
number one, the presence of a father.
Isn't that interesting?
Because men are considered to be less
empathetic and women are more empathetic.
Presence of the father is the number one
predictor of their further development
of empathy. Number two, it's free
plate in nature, free play in edge.
And my daughter's really
into this right now.
Like we have toads that live by our house,
so we have a froggy pardon,
I'm far away. And she's learning
a lot about how to handle things,
delicately had a play with them
and all of that. She's great,
great with the animals and frequently
in nature and the presence of a father.
Now what's happened over the
past 40 years and as society,
kids don't get free
play in nature anymore.
Most of it's scheduled shit in the gym,
you know,
with the dance classes and
all that thrombus that was,
but give them free play in nature of
the glorious anarchy of childhood where
it's just like he doesn't have
to do and go do something. Right.
That's number one.
And number two,
of course it's dads and vanished
from so many households.
And this is why in the last 15 years
sociopathy one of the most malignant forms
of distractive personality
traits, sociopath, he has
doubled in the last 15 years.
I'm not sure what that term means. What
sociopathy, uh, people who, um, uh,
grandiose zero conscience,
they use other people there superficially
charming but never keep their promises.
So especially if they have no,
they have no conscience at all.
And then we'll know measurable conscience,
like you can show that the most horrifying
stuff where you and I is our brains
would light up like Christmas trees.
Right? And they just, they don't care.
They don't have any particular, and
this is doubled in our society, uh, to,
to the point when Alec Between One and
25 and one in 20 people are sociopaths.
I mean that's tens of direct correlation
between that growing up with a father
and not being, well, those
are two significant risk
factors. There's other stuff,
you know, physical abilities, how
do they calculate and all that.
So they just find sociopath and work
backwards, back end what they do big,
you know, the big studies, uh,
and they asked people all of the
questions and sociopath's filled reliant,
you'd get stuff wrong because they just
don't have empathy. They can fake it,
you know,
they kind of know that's what's expected,
but they don't actually feel
empathy for other people.
And you can find that with
a series of questions.
You can also measure their brains and
find out how they react to certain stimuli
and how it's different for
the rest of the population.
And they do big studies on that.
And then they extrapolate that
to the population as a whole.
We were talking about Fm Ris, uh, on
the, before this recording started,
he was gripping. Shit,
we've got another crappy,
we audio engineer and put it all together.
But the fascinating thing about Fmis,
being able to measure various aspects
of the brain and reactions to certain
things, um, on my television
show and have you ever seen it?
It's called Joe Rogan
questions. Everything. Well,
one of the things we did was watching.
We've talked to,
can you want a new word rather?
It's beautiful thing.
It's actually from that finding
bigfoot show there. Yeah.
Yeah. Talking about it long
before my show, but we, um,
I spoke to a woman who is a,
an,
she was an expert on,
uh,
use of the EEG and Mri and she said that
there was actually a court case where a
woman was convicted because she had
functional knowledge of a crime scene and
it's based on Fsri wow.
That she had functional knowledge of
a murder scene and the woman who was a
neurologist felt that it was very
dangerous because she said there can be
functional knowledge of something based
on how much have they talked to you
about this crime scene.
Have you formulated imagery in your head?
Have they shown you
photographs of the scene?
How do they like what places
and how do we know what,
what aspect of it relies on personal
creativity or the imagination to sort of
conceive him and played out in your head
and then that this is registered on the
FM awry.
It's fascinating,
fascinating stuff where we're getting
to really understand the various
components of what makes us a human being.
What memory is really tricky. Do
you, do you have these things?
I have these things,
Joe,
where like I had stories about
my childhood and I swear to God,
I could not tell you if they're true or
not. I don't know if I heard that story.
Somebody told it so many times now I
don't know if I'm in France and there's a
rep half of the planet or Deborah, I
mean I'm not sure. Like I don't know.
I did the stories like, oh, I
remember when you did this and I mean,
I don't know if it got
extrapolated or it got nec.
I don't honestly know like you know,
pictures of it. It didn't happen.
But I don't know. And I think that's
true for a lot of people like you,
you can tell you talk
yourself in and how to stuff.
They did a study recently that blew my
mind about people's ethical integrity,
right?
So they did a study where they got
people to agree with a particular ethical
statement. I agree with
this ethical statement ever
abortion is bad or whatever.
They get ethical state and then they
had them close the book and then they,
the book stuck a new word that made
it exactly the opposite statement.
Right. And now agree with this thing
that I formally condemned as the youth.
Right.
They opened it up and they ask them,
can you just read that again
and tell us what you think?
About 70 to 80% of the people would read
it again and completely agree with the
exact opposite statement that they've
made, not three minutes before.
And had great reasons
for it too. Wow. I mean,
this is the level of fluid unreality
that people live in and it's really
dangerous and we all live in.
Yeah.
And we all have to fight
this tendency for sure.
Well,
I've had real issues with people when
you talk to them about past events and
they start giving it an incredibly
distorted, self-serving version of it.
And I wonder whether or not they really
believe this or not. And then I'm,
I'm really,
um,
I'm a big proponent of
if I criticize something,
I criticize myself first because I think
that if I criticized the various aspect
of human nature, like memory, my memory
is fantastic and yet fucking terrible.
You know, I can go like when I do
the ultimate fighting championship,
when I do the broadcast for
the fights, I, you know, I can
run a law statistics. You are, um, you
are great with names. Thank you. Yeah,
no you are.
Because for me people might as well just
introduce themselves to me with like,
Hello Andrew. Angela. Cause that's all
I got. Three minutes. Same concept.
But you just like Blah Blah remains just
trip off of your time. And I think grab,
well especially when it comes to like
mixed martial arts or something that I'm
passionate about, I can remember details
of fights, very important things.
But like last night,
last night show was amazing.
I've been looking forward to it for a
longest time as a rod to be part of like
that was a killer chef. Oh, it's real.
A lot of fun. So it's 3000 people.
I'm on stage for an hour and 20 minutes
and if you had access to my memory of
that night,
it would be blurry snap shots.
Remember Hacivat oh yeah. Did I do that
job? I don't remember if I did that. Joe.
I have notes.
I mean I have it in the moment.
If you can remember it too well
and you were watching yourself.
You weren't in it. Yes, but it's,
but it's a huge event for me.
Important once a year thing where I come
to Toronto and yet my memory of it is
this incredibly cloudy thing
and it's like that is the case.
I think with most human beings when it
comes to memory and we were looking at,
we look at memory and we try to pretend
as if my memory is locked solid,
you know, it's, it's in there. I
bolted in, it's screwed in place. Yeah,
it's not going anywhere. And that's
nonsense. The mind doesn't work that way.
There's various things you can remember.
I remember how to use this
espresso machine and pushed
a little carton in there.
I press that button and the junk
comes out. But you know, the, the,
the reality of my day, like what
went on today, it's just snapshots,
like weird flashbacks of food,
Iaa,
jokes that we tell them. It's
very strange, the human mind.
I think one of the emerging aspects of
technology that I'm incredibly fascinated
with is this symbiotic relationship
that we're starting to have with,
with computers, machines, Google glass.
I think we're going to develop an
artificial way of recording things or an
artificial way of recording
life that's going to be like,
I'm going to be able to, you know, Stefan,
please check out my day and drop off my
day and you're going to roll with like,
Holy Shit, why don't you fucking
terrified in this as well.
This is a crazy moment. Like
what? We won't be able to
call each other I man. Yeah.
It'd be a little bit fast
forward into this lives and,
and share what you know that
a bunch of lawyers and trying to get in
touch with the NSA these days because
the NSA records everything. Right?
And so they're saying, look,
I mean for my court case,
you guys know his cell phone was here,
but he was talking on it and they say
he was here, but then sell a company,
doesn't have records.
Go back two years. You,
you guys can get this guy had a Jane
doe and the freedom of information acts.
They're just hammering these guys trying
to get facts out to get people out of
jail or put people in jail.
I think they don't want to really
completely admit that they are recording
everything. I mean, when Obama
addressed that situation,
it's easier to record everything. And then
some things. What if we applied this on
and off when he said something important?
We were just recording about a data.
It's not a concern. We're not
spying on Americans. Yeah, yeah.
The fuck you're not man.
They're spying on everyone and they're
putting it all in these gigantic hard
drugs and the APP.
No,
I mean hydride spaces so cheap now,
but I've always lived like, it's all,
it's being recorded ever since I
went online. Smart. Oh, come on.
It makes a smart way to do it. And
it's showing now at this point in time,
but that is if you send something,
if you transmit something,
someone can receive it. If
someone can pick it up, someone
can enter, intercept it.
It's a, it's a very strange aspect, but
again, as as we were talking about before,
I think it,
we are in an adolescent stage of this
relationship that we have to technology in
this relationship that
we have to information.
I think ultimately it's going to get
to a point where there is no boundary
between your information
or my information.
And I think with that really gets weird
is with money because money essentially,
right now it's just ones and Zeros
and when you get down to this,
there's a finite point of this finite
barrier and that barrier breaks and there
is no, there's no boundary
between anyone in information.
Mine is just information. It can start
getting really fucking weird. Yeah.
Money is agreed bullshit.
It is. It's like that's,
both will give me this bullshit and real.
Right. That's how churches get built.
Yeah. But money is just
this complete fiction as you
pointed out. I mean, you know,
it used to be used to be old.
It used to be some stuff you
had to dig out of the ground.
You couldn't just make it up like that.
Right. But the main effect buying this,
you mentioned $85 billion worth of
treasuries. They didn't have that money.
It's not like they went
out and made it out. Man,
that was a long shift at the weight at
the pizza had to get those tips, man.
They just,
they type whatever they want into their
bank account and we don't think that's
going to corrupt human beings. I
mean Kippy a breath. It's so strange.
It's so strange.
And W we,
we live in the weirdest time when it comes
to money as well because of the whole
collapsing the banks and the bailouts
and the president getting on television
and saying he's going to limit the Ala,
the guys who we bailed out and he's going
to limit their fucking bonuses to half
a million dollars. And we're like,
what? Where's that money coming from?
Is that all our money? You're going to
take our money? Who are you to give it to?
These guys, it's a bonus for
failing, like the banks failed.
And so they get a boat.
Like what are you saying?
Like what is this madness we're living?
Well, Obama of course, you know,
there's some theories that the, one of
the main reasons he got elected, he took,
he took the most money at all
the candidates from Wall Street,
from the financial companies. And I mean,
what's he gonna do? Throw them in jail?
Like they just did this fine.
I think it was yesterday, um,
at JP Morgan got hit with a fine of
$920 million. Right? And first of all,
that's just bail out money.
They're handing back, you know,
the boob burning money here. You, oh,
it's back. Right? But secondly, I mean,
let's say that they did, they seem to
have admitted to some legal stuff, right?
So they did the legal stuff,
which costs their clients a lot of money,
or the client's getting the money back.
No government gets it.
It's like phoning the cops and say,
somebody stole my car. The Cop said, we,
we found it. Are we gonna keep it,
but we found it. I mean, government,
why would the government
get the money for what JP Morgan
did to ripoff it's customers.
Plus the JP Morgan employees aren't
going to get racist because I mean,
but the JP Morgan executives, they
don't pay anything. It's a corporation.
I mean they can't pay,
I mean the corporation is just this
abstract fiction that people make up that
shield themselves from legal consequences.
So everyone's like,
oh well they got fine. So they, you know,
somehow the JP Morgan executives
are out that money and it's like,
no they're not. I mean they're never
going to get thrown in jail for anything.
Never,
never going to get thrown in jail for
things that the average person would be
locked up for the rest of their life
if they were involved in fraud at that
level, if they were involved.
I mean just think about,
just think about what when people go to
jail for just for what they do with the
stock market for manipulation, the stock
market. I mean that is essentially a,
how much different is that really?
Then what goes on with the banking crisis?
I mean,
you're talking about moving money around,
you talking about manipulating things
and figuring out a way to profit from
these manipulations. Yeah. How is,
how was insider trading any different
from what these guys have done?
Well, it's not any, I mean,
if you want to talk about
manipulating the stock market,
I mean the Federal Reserve buying the
treasury bonds just because nobody else
wants those pieces of shit frankly. Right?
I mean, the Chinese are sick of them.
The Indians,
it's a sick of them.
The Japanese are sick of them because
they know that they can't possibly be
redeemed without hyperinflation
or some other defaults. Right.
As either a software heart, he thought
they know that that stuff is junk.
So the Fed is buying them just to prop
up the prices and they're doing that.
So all the other governments don't have
to admit that they're basically toilet
paper's in Bob Wheaton, you know,
Donald Mill toilet paper. Yeah.
And it's all just this crazy thing
that they can't possibly sustain.
You know that this show, once they'd
been about 240, like just paper,
only coffee accounts, right? Paper
only money in a history of the world.
240 240 different ones, different, just
different, you know, they, you know,
some government gets in power,
the issue,
some bullshit currency and then it
blows up and then they issue some new
currency,
whatever.
And there's only one of them that's
still in circulation from a couple of
hundred years ago.
It's the British pounds though.
It's last like 97% of its value in the
dollars last like 98% of it's value since
the Fed came in in 1913. Uh,
and um, and people say gas,
it's expensive. It's not, if you guess
it's cheaper now than it was in 1960.
If you pay for it and silver,
if you pay for it.
And this paper a shit that the
hand around pretending it's money,
it's really expensive because
it's been devalued so much.
When I first came to Canada in
1977 I was like 11 years old.
I can get a candy bar for it now.
You don't now and within like 10 years.
So it was like a buck because they're
just printing all this crazy money.
Printing money is a great gig because
you get to hand it out to all the people
who are voting for you and then the
inflation hits like two years later and
nobody can connect the dots.
It's beautiful.
And plus everyone blames
the local supermarket for
raising the prices as if they
want to write. But it's all the central
printing money stuff is just really,
really dangerous. And it brought down the
Roman empire was exactly the same way.
They just kept putting more and more crap
into their money until what was Sylvan
and areas which originally 100% silver.
It ended up being like one and a half
percent silver with basically like,
you know, Zombie teeth, that
Harish shit thrown into it. Right?
And it just destroys the entire,
the entire economy.
And this is going to have to be this
huge reset and the global economy.
So what's,
how is that?
I'm going to happen.
I mean w w what's fascinating is that now
that we have this incredible access to
information and now that you know,
people like you were putting
this stuff out there and it's,
it's become a part of the narrative.
People understand what's wrong.
It's not just a matter of it goes wrong
and it takes years for people to put the
pieces together and then you have to
go to school and learn what's wrong.
It's really right in front of your
face. What's wrong? What happens now,
do you think that there's
an adjustment period?
Do you think that because of this ink,
this incredible
groundswell of information,
do you think that it can be re engineered?
Can it be redesigned? Can it, can we,
can we somehow or another
bitcoin our way out of it?
Well, there's a long term solution
which I think is multigenerational,
which has to do with
treating kids batterer right?
Raising them rationally and not using
aggression on them and all that.
So there's a long term solution. I mean,
the short term solution I think is just,
you know,
trying to invest in human capital and
try and convert paper currency into
something tangible like real estate
or gold or something like that.
I think those are sensible strategies
that lots of people who've been on my show
and all the economists will talk about.
I think that's all good stuff. Um,
I think what's going to happen in the
short run is obviously the government's
going to run out of money. I mean,
no matter how much they print,
they're just going to run out of money.
And then what happens is there's
going to be talk a sacrifice now,
not the kind of sacrifice
like forget the second car,
stay home with your kids that
we've been talking about before,
but like real hard and sacrifice.
So they're gonna say, well,
we spent the on remains for
so long. You've seen this
happened before in history.
And they just basically turn
on the dependent classes, they,
of welfare recipients to live on less
social security recipients who live on
less and they're just start squeezing
the dependent classes because that's the
biggest single bail. And
also you'll, you will see,
which of course is the goal of
a lot of overseas terrorists.
You will see the u s begin to withdraw
the imperial presence in the world. Right?
They got over 700 military bases all over
the world. That's an expensive stuff.
Is that really the number now? Seven over
700 I think 720 now. That's incredible.
Oh, it's crazy. When we talk
about like the Roman Empire,
when people talk about getting
this con constantly in the world,
like it was nothing. Okay, this guy was
basically just a fuck machine. You know,
like I took a third of people in that
section of the world can trace their
lineage back to that guy. I mean he
was working overtime and he like,
he never did the gate of all.
I think that by trying to
say it was pretty amazing.
When you think about how
much damage they did though,
you really will read or listen to Dan
Carlin show hardcore history. Yeah,
he's been on my show actually. Yeah,
he's got a great show. Great Guy.
He's his piece on the con,
the wrath of the cons with
five part piece. Um, the, the,
the incredible accomplishments
of Ganga scars.
Mongol hoards, no. Yeah,
they're responsible for the
death of at least 20 million,
perhaps 70 million people
like depending on the ass.
How over the course of his lifetime
and the lifetime the sons like
that's the bad shit man forces pad
stuff, horses, horses, arrows, the killed
at least 20 million people. I mean that,
I mean, once you're on hook in
a while, like that's a lot of,
you haven't tried pulling a boat.
I mean those are real close
to the of the compound. Yeah.
Those clothes would acquire 160
pounds of pressure to pull. Yeah.
I mean like at one point you just give
him a fucking arm flies off, you know,
that you don't even like,
it doesn't even shoot an arrow anymore.
You're just arm goes
across like a boomerang.
I don't know what you do at that point.
And they had women that could pull those
bolts and shoot from a horse like that.
A Bullseye while you're awesome thundering
along. I mean also shoots sideways,
talked under the Horse. Oh, right, right.
I couldn't get hit from
arrows from the side. Right.
There were like shielding themselves.
I mean if that was still going on,
would you take narrating that job?
That's my costume come up with. That'd
be pretty exciting stuff. It would.
Right, right. It's a completely violation,
but the non aggression principle,
sorry Theo.
The beautiful thing about the UFC is
it's a mutually agreed upon competition.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
A character contest,
a contest of will and planning and
discipline and to me it's, you know,
the ultimate fighting championship
is to me literally the ultimate in
competition for a human being. As far as
like, I don't think it's for everybody,
it's certainly not,
but I think as far as like the amount of
time and energy and focus and then the
maintenance and the control of
your emotions during a contest,
because you're literally putting your
health online and your consciousness,
you can get incredibly badly hurt.
I think it's one of the reasons
why it's so incredibly exciting
and the discipline you,
I can't remember the name of the final,
but you're saying it's one guy who
keeps a list of everything he wants to
accomplish by his bed and like [inaudible]
first thing that he gets up and I'm
finding it just focuses on that stuff.
Favor doesn't, same thing. Yeah.
They both hate each other.
Twin smelling. Let me,
let me spin your theory
because we're talking about
the fighting stuff and I was,
I was watching the show
last night and I was,
I was thinking about like
why is this occurring?
Like why people could be doing anything
with their time and money that come in
here to see some really funny stuff.
I was thinking about a
lot of the stuff that,
that you and the other two comics
talked about is pretty visceral, right?
I mean you, you've, you've got
this great phrase that you use. Um,
the monkey energy,
you know,
like you've got this crazy monkey energy
when you can't pay your mortgage and
you know,
you've got to go out and do something
physical because your body thinks there's
like a tiger jumping at you and stuff
like that. And I was really struck by,
you know, Dick fart jokes
and stuff like that. I mean,
come jokes and stuff like that.
They're funny.
But I think it's really interesting the
degree to which people respond to that
because it's not polite conversation.
You know this,
I've never seen a sign outside
the box office relative to yours.
It says the most extreme possible
language will be used. Like do not,
if you, if you like Jane Austen,
your head is gonna explode in here.
Like it's just not
same sign since like the 1990s
actually that sign I put up,
it's on my first CD, which is
called, I'm going to be dead Sunday,
which released in 1999. And the, the,
that sign was something that I started
putting up in comedy clubs because I got
tired of people complaining
and I said it would contain,
this show will contain the most
extreme content. Imagine that.
Yeah. And it really did like I
have a pretty good imagination.
They might have less did and
cam class. Well, no, that's
good. I mean that was good.
That was good. So I was thinking, okay,
but why are people so drawn to this?
Because it is a very common
component of comedy and all that.
And let me give you a tiny theory and
then you can tell me that as an outside
non comedian, I'm completely
bullish yet, which is fine, but,
but I just sort of idea like we supposed
to be United in what to me is just a
lot of crap. You know, like
countries, patriotism, socialism,
uh, our God, our saints are
whatever our client are like,
it's all nonsense.
And it doesn't actually connect people
because it's kind of fantastic. Right?
I mean nobody, even countries,
they don't even really exist.
They really colors on a map.
They call them tax farms,
but they don't really
exist like a real thing.
But where we can connect.
And I think where this comedy show last
night really did help people connect was
we are all mammals,
you know,
and we have these bodily functions and
we have these impulses and these urges
and these fantasies. Like the first
guy talking about his fantasy of yeah,
it'll Gadol Brian Cowen. Yeah.
Brilliant stuff. Brilliant stuff.
And anything again.
And I'm English enough to know that
anything that marks the French gets up
anyway. But, um,
so I think that there's this like monkey
meetup club that goes on in comedy
clubs where we do connect to that really
visceral level of, you know, of shitting,
of fucking, of farting, of, of,
of sex drives of, of, you know,
the guy took it and got in the elevator,
was talking to said that one of the
funniest things to be that night with the
noise you made when he was done,
forgot to breathe when he's eating
so much that you'd be here. Right.
But it's hilarious because we walk
in there like, this food is so good.
Why am I can't see out of my
to do like that is that we want and
these are also really common experiences
that we really can't talk about because
we live in these refined abstracts and
countries and religions
and clubs and all that,
but here at this level we really do,
I think connect in a very visceral way
and there was so much talked about it in
terms of connection and I
think the audience is laughing
because we never get to
talk about how we connect
and an animal level.
Then I was thinking about the UFC as well,
that a lot of your life I think is around
getting people to connect at a very
visceral animal level and animal level.
Sounds bad.
I don't mean it that way at all.
I think it's really,
this is where we do connect at the
beginning. You know, we connect in sex,
we connect and fighting,
we connect finally primally and there.
I think a lot of your work has to do with
that and fear factor is also involved.
That's really primal stuff. Primal
fears that people have confronted them,
overcoming them. People watching that. I
think can really connect with that fear,
with that desire for the money and the
fear of the circumstances and all that.
But the prime
fear of competition itself, the, the,
the fear of failing, the fear of, uh,
overcoming adversity or not
being able to, that's, that's a,
a real part of being person is
the challenges of life itself.
And with fear factor is a stupid
show. You know, don't give me all,
I don't have any grandiose ideas
of what taglines for that. Right.
How was the factor?
It's a stupid show really show it was
entertaining and I know people enjoyed it,
but the, what is, what was
fascinating to me, it was,
I have a background in martial arts and
in competition. More importantly, um, I,
I thought most of my life
from age 15 to age 22,
it's basically all I did with my time.
And so I understand what it's like to
be confronted with a daunting task and
understand what it's like to be standing
there when the referee looks at you and
goes, are you ready? You know and
then looks at the other guy and goes,
are you ready? Go. You know, in that
moment that like here it is, Whoa,
like a cliff, right? I mean it's a very
strange thing for us to just say, ready,
go and then go do something.
It's, it's really hard to do,
to do it like to anticipate and also
as human beings we can counter and all
these different variables and one of
the things about being an intelligent
person and facing a difficult competition,
whether it's fighting or anything
incredibly hard, he's like,
you were aware of the variables,
you're aware of the failure,
the wear of the humiliation,
your well where have the embarrassment
of failure you where we are.
If the personal dissatisfaction with
your own performance in depression that's
going to come with that and all those
variables they can combine to create like
a constriction effect where you
just almost can't perform you,
you're,
you're overwhelmed by the possibilities
and you would just freak the fuck out.
It's called being dwarfed by the moment
the moment comes and it's one of the
things that I was good at on fear factor
is to talk people through that and just
to let them know like, look,
you can fucking do this.
You just go out and you don't think
about anything else but doing it.
All those other things are attract.
Those other things are demons.
You got to keep those demons
at bay. Don't, don't entertain
them. Don't feed them.
Don't give them water. Push them
away. They don't exist. Well,
you're going to concentrate
on as repeating the mantra
that you can do this and
this is how you're going to do it.
Be in the moment and go do this,
and I helped a lot of people get through
that show because of that and that that
has a primal thing that's up.
That's the difference between someone
who survives an encounter with a Jaguar
and someone who does it.
You know that someone who packs and
freezes up and gets killed and someone who
runs away,
someone figures out how to climb a tree.
Somebody figures out how to pick a rock
and smash it into had the, the, the,
the difference between
someone who encounters an
incredibly difficult situation
and learns from it or dies because of it.
That's a primal thing,
man.
I mean that is one of the reasons why
we're here is because people did confront
predators.
And the reason why children are afraid
at night of monsters is because we have
genetic, they're monsters,
jaguars and leopards eating us.
I remember reading
a story about a guy who got
bitten bike, right? Right.
Shot and not like it bitten went
off like it took his whole torso.
It is math and it's math and it swam in
the water with him and he was so dazed.
He said he remembered it all very vividly
and cause like he wasn't a head injury
right here.
You forget stuff then. Right. But he was,
he was under the water and he was just
being basically pulled along into the
deep water by the shark,
which hadn't been this in his joints
and he was just dates and he was like,
I'm fucked. You know? Okay, well,
what am I going to do here? Right.
And then did the image of his kids
came up and his wife and he's like,
no fucking way. And he just
reached up and he jammed his hand,
the end of the eye of the sharp.
Wow. And it shook him free.
They'd let go because you know, I
guess that hurts. I can imagine. Right.
And he's slammed at the surface and
he lived and he made it back to shore
because there's that moment where
you just go like, no fucking way.
I'm not going out like this. And that I
think is that thing. That's the primal,
visceral response.
Whereas before it was just like,
I'm going to surrender to this God awful
thing. And then it's just like, no,
no way. No Way. I'm fighting back this.
Well, that's what's fascinating. Well,
martial arts competition is that
everyone has a sort of no way thing,
but the reality of no way is if you're
in the octagon with John Jones and you
say, no way, it doesn't
matter what you think.
He said,
no way he's going to kill you.
I won't keep it that I'm like a fine red
mist of nothingness in about 10 seconds.
Some has been,
they've prepared their entire life for
this moment and it's not just the no way
that you get when you're
getting bit by a shark,
but it's also knowing that that no
way is coming every fucking day.
Getting up at 5:00 AM when the alarm
clock goes off and eating healthy and
running and making sure you have the
right amount of rest and take the right
amount of vitamins and all that.
Knowing that you have that instinct
to say no way, but so does he,
and that's not going to be good
enough. Right, right. You're going to,
you're going to have to control your body,
control your mind,
developed your skills and
have an intelligent approach
to this very difficult
task in front of you
and you you've talked about,
but when you were a kid that
you saw violence in your home.
Fortunately of course, incredibly sorry.
Is it true that for a lot of these guys,
they come from rough backgrounds and
some aggressive or violent backgrounds?
A lot of them, almost all of them. And
what do you think the connection is there?
Because in some ways you sort of think,
well, if you saw that kind of stuff,
wouldn't you want to get away from it?
Well you would,
but sometimes you can't. And so you
want to learn to protect yourself.
And that's what a lot of it is. And a
lot of it is, a lot of guys were bullied.
I was bullied not too badly.
I'm a, nobody really hurt me,
but I was intimidated by a lot of guys,
you know,
like scared and it gets in your head,
the bullying,
it just circles around your house,
humiliating. It's humiliating it, it can,
you know, it causes people to jump off
buildings. You know, it's, it's, it's a,
it's a huge,
huge problem with human beings,
this natural inclination to pick
on the weak, to satisfy our own,
our own insecurities, you know?
And um, uh, for me, I was,
I was a small kid.
I wasn't big.
And there was just too many moments
where I was scared and I was like, okay,
this is not how I want to live my life.
So I started taking martial arts.
I was like, I got to learn how to
fight cause this just too scary.
You don't want,
environment doesn't get an end.
You get exactly the fraternity like this
is going to be the rest of my life and
the environment is not going to change
at the teachers aren't going to stop it.
There's no way for my parents to stop it
like if I don't act this is going to be
the same fucking day
for the rest of my life.
It was clear to me,
it was clear to me that no one was
going to help me and as a boy it was a,
one of the core issues of being a boy
growing up was dealing with the other boys
and this balance of power which
was so against me. I was like,
this is one of the things,
a lot of the findings,
you know that story of
the kids in the jungle,
they think it's like some island
somewhere. When a plane goes down,
I mean it's high school. I went to
boarding school. I mean it's, it's not,
it's not some island out there.
It's like walking into the end of the
school building. It's human nature,
nature. And there's the dance,
like who's the Alpha? Like what's,
what's going to go on here?
Like who's going to be the one
that controls the situation?
Who's going to get the first pick of the
girls? Who's going to get, you know, what,
who, who gets to pick on
people and get away with it.
And that is a part of
being a human beings.
And it's also a part of being a
human being. The, as you said,
is developing in a society where children
not being raised correctly. So you're,
you're not, if a child grows
up with martial arts as a,
as a young boy,
you'd be incredibly embarrassed to be a
bullying because that is the worst thing
you could ever be in a martial arts class.
I am a black belt in Jujitsu and I roll
on a regular basis roaming spar with
people who are complete novices
and I don't hurt them ever.
I've never heard one and you know I just,
I and I coached them along the way.
I'm like you've got to,
you've got attorneys that right
does it like they don't want to keep
hitting my daughter cause were play
wrestling.
It's like for what have I been doing that
for mean sometimes it's big strong men,
they're on trend.
But
the point is like if,
if I like humiliated them or beat
them up or something like that,
it would be a massive
embarrassment for my school.
A massive verus would for
me as a martial artist,
like everyone in class
would hate me because of it.
There are people like that that do like
bully and tried to hurt like lesser
ranks or or novices. Those people are
kicked out of class like they, they,
there's no place for them.
In martial arts,
it's about developing character and then
about representing that development and
character,
like having honor and having respect
and if kids learn that at an early age
there'd be no bullying in class,
there would be none of that.
There's always going to be people picking
on people and people make making fun
of people. But bullying is specific like
ganging up on people and taking them.
That's that.
That is one of the scariest aspects of
growing up and it motivates a lot of
martial artists to to learn
and that's what motivated me.
So ultimately it's like this terribly
negative force channels itself into an
incredibly positive thing that really
became a developing factor for every
aspect of my life and it became a,
it became a real vehicle.
One of the, I love music sprays a
vehicle for developing human potential,
so there's no, no, go
ahead. When you find out,
because it's so you find out what you can
do and then other things become easier.
Yeah, I think the mastery of
anything that's really challenging.
I think great things for self esteem.
Now when you started taking the martial
lights, what happened with the bullying?
I mean,
did you end up beating people up or did
you end up having the confidence that
they then found a week or prey?
Very few physical altercations
outside of competitions?
You know,
I have like one or two small ones in
high school that were really no big deal.
Um,
the nothing like crazy,
but the fights that I had in
tournament's were so extreme, you know,
like so many knockouts and
just so, so much. Craig,
the violence of physical competition is
so much more intense than anything you'd
ever experience in, in, uh, your
average street fight. You know,
like you're dealing with trained killers
like you and another train killer dude.
So like there was no motivation for me
to prove to anybody that I knew how to
fight. And then somewhere along
the line other kids do like, oh,
that's a, he's a black belt, he's this,
he's that. And they just left me alone.
So it became just become scary enough.
They leave you alone and then you
don't, you know, you avoid the fight.
Even voice is always better than cure.
Right.
And you have very little aggression
because you're always training.
So like when you train all the time,
you're always tired.
Like you know you have no, yeah.
People Think, oh my God, he's so fit.
I think of all the energy you'd
have. It's like, oh my God,
I just got to get from the Futon, but the
cash, somebody give me a wheel better.
It was a famous,
yeah.
Karate master who once said
that the, the, the Tara Tika is,
or not a nicer,
yeah,
just tired from training.
They avoid these things because they just,
it's too hard to just get up for it.
Right, right. But I think that human
beings have a massive amount of,
you know what I, I called Chimp Dna,
that th the, the monkey instincts,
there's a massive amount of those that
are not being represented by the way we
live our lives,
the,
the bodies that we have are essentially
the same bodies is the humility,
is that live to a hundred thousand
years ago or 50,000 years ago?
It was very little
variation. Yeah. And the the,
the need for physical movement and the
need for just the activity and all these
different,
these different hormones and chemicals
that your body just naturally produces.
They have to be satisfied. They have
to be, they have to be moved around.
And I think it's a huge part of
balancing your perspective in life,
balancing your view of the world.
It just to exercise these things out
of your system and for boys especially.
Huge,
huge part of being sane.
Yeah. Certainly learning how to
manage aggression is really important.
I think one of the,
yeah,
I'm in a strong atheist and I think one
of the things that was really harmful
about religion was this
idea that we are antibody,
that we are souls trapped in this
prison of the flesh and we're,
you know him to be these rockets that
rise up to meet the glory above and
someone, because I think that gave us
this feeling that the body is somehow,
and it's very explicit in some forms of
Christianity and other too that the body
is Satan's device to draw you away from
God the lasts and then all that other
stuff that the comedians
make fun of it and celebrate.
I think it's very probiotic,
right?
Cause it's funny and it's
an enjoyable place to be.
And I think that this hostility towards,
it's called in philosophy,
the mind body dichotomy
that we have this glorious,
my attracted this horrible fleshly chorus
kind of thing. I think it's really,
really unhealthy. And I didn't really
get that when I was young. Like when,
when I was 20 I went to the
national theater school,
I was going to be an actor
and a playwright. And then
some of that for a bit.
But what they did there,
which I thought was amazing,
was real bodywork, which I'd never been
exposed to before and grew up in England,
you know, evens relationship to the
body is, you know, and it's crazy,
right when you can clean their teeth.
I love the taste of ginger fighters in the
morning and I was like, empire. But, um,
when I did this body work, which was like
a, I don't feel the Alexandra technique,
which is a binary repositioning
technique that we did gymnastics,
we did a sword fighting,
we did play yellow stage fighting
and all that kind of stuff,
which is like in some ways more
challenging. And uh, we did, um,
the stretching and,
and I got into yoga and stuff like that.
And I always encouraging this in my
shell because an idea with a pretty hyper
intellectual audience, and I keep
trying to remind people, you know,
drive your brain back into the body,
drive your brain back into the idea that
as a seed of everything that you are,
and you know,
if that doesn't do well,
you're not going to do well in the long
run and don't split yourself off from
the body.
But there's this weird thing in society
where we are somehow not our bodies and
it has to do with the sole idea.
We can continue afterwards and I don't
think I'm going to have any more reality
after I'm death. And I did before I
was born, which is to say not at all.
And this is,
this is where we are.
And I really try to encourage people to
really root themselves in that. You know,
we have a second brain called the gap,
which is almost as complex as the one
we've got up here. And people say,
I've got to get instinct. That's, that's
real. That's not an imaginary thing.
There's this great book by
Malcolm Gladwell called Blink.
You should pick it up if you haven't read
or have. Yeah. Okay, so when he says,
you know,
people get stuff like so incredibly
quickly and that's not a intellectual
process. That is a full body
process and I think the people,
you know in terms of you say,
well how do we heal the world?
I think our bodies detect in morality
a lot quicker than our brains do.
Like you don't have those people.
They'd come around, you're like, man,
there's something not
right about this guy.
I don't know if body language they
look perfectly normal or whatever.
If it's a slight vacancies in the eyes
or something like that or was overly
stiff body posture or something like that.
I think that if we could see,
you call them, I think exquisite noose
bags they you're talking about now,
but it takes down hopes
the party in the desert.
Then he could have these parties but
there'd be a thousand cool guys and then
one unbelievable Douche bag who
would just ruin it for everyone.
I think we can see those people,
but I think we can mostly see them
with the body and heart with the brain
because the brain,
we can talk herself in and out of stuff.
But the Bonnie I think really connects
at a very visceral level with the people
that were around us. And I think if we
could train people to be more in the body,
I think they'd be better at detecting
bullshit and better at detecting bad
people and shunning them.
And then we kind of isolate them in
quarantine them not breed with them that
having motor fucking upper kids.
And I think then we'd be able to pass
that gene out of the pool so to speak.
Sorry,
there's a hell of a lot rent.
No,
absolutely on.
And I think that the idea that the
body is separate from the mind,
it's really kind of silly.
It's they, they, they, they,
they work together and if the mind is
working overtime and the body is falling
apart though the mind's
not to be at its optimum.
Even if you have an incredibly advanced
mine and beautiful knowledge and
information, it would be better
if your body isn't shaped.
It'd be better if you were limber.
It'd be better if you
were weren't stressed out.
Like we experience a physical
stress of the deteriorating bodies.
It's legitimate. It's 100%
real. It's not just a um, uh,
a vain thing. Do you want to keep your
body in shape to look good? You know,
it's an ego thing. It's
not, it's, it's, you're,
you are some weird symbiotic thing,
you know,
it's the mind and the body and
then also the intestinal flora.
It gets really freaky when
you start realizing that
you're actually an ecosystem.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It was one thing.
And the ecosystem is even within the mind
as this great therapy called internal
family systems therapy,
which basically says that we are,
we don't have like a single south, like
we are competing ecosystem of, you know,
our parents and those who want
stuff from us in our, you know,
some of our own needs, which is also
to please those who wants that from us.
And it's all it competing. And if you
think that you've gotten like one ego,
you end up being a kind of tyrant because
all these other voices in your head
telling you to do stuff or
encouraged me to do stuff,
kind of kept him down cause we need unity.
But I think the idea that we are always
in a state of negotiation with ourselves,
uh, is really positive. And you know,
I spent years in therapy and I think
it's just fantastic to work for that kind
of approach that we have. I call it the
Mikko system like me as an ecosystem. Uh,
and,
and it really is a lot of give and take
and a lot of negotiation with yourself.
And of course,
if you can negotiate with yourself,
I think you'll end up with a society
where people negotiate with each other.
I think that the people who are tyrannical
with their own identity and that
being tyrannical, but with others, I
think that the way the world is out there,
it's very much a mirror of
the way we live internally.
And if we can be more at
peace and negotiating with
ourselves and recognize that
we should not have a single
dominant authority within ourselves,
but everything is a negotiation,
you know,
do I want to work out or I
don't want to have an APP.
I mean I have those negotiations with
myself all the time and that way I can
negotiate with my wife and
my daughter and my she,
my listeners and all that and I don't have
a tyrannical part of myself that says,
well you just got to do this.
God Damn it no matter what.
Because I'm always afraid that if that's
the way it is for me in there, in here,
that's how it's going to
translate to the world out there.
I always feel that the, the, the,
the most massive structures in the
world and the government states,
armies and all that, just a reflection
of how we deal with ourselves internally.
And I think try and get people to relax
about how they deal with themselves
internally and negotiating more than
dictate. I think it's really important.
I'm completely rambling,
but I hope that makes some makes sense.
And the,
the rigidity,
being rigid and not being able
to be flexible about things.
There's also you just shoo the ability
to alter your ideas about things and not
feel like you're loser because you
changed your mind.
You know,
like the ability to admit mistakes and
to be able to express where the mistake
went wrong and what, what he believed.
Now. I think that that's very important.
I think one of the,
the things that I see in people that I
admire is one of the things I admire most
is the ability to make, make wrong,
the ability to make mistakes,
the ability to admit,
admit personal failures,
and then the ability to grow
from learning about that mistake.
And one of the things that I find to be
one of the most incredibly weak and I
intolerable things is someone
who cannot admit they're wrong.
I can't communicate with people like
that. I can't, I can't. Yeah, I've,
I make mistakes all the
time. If you don't, you know,
maybe you're the perfect person,
but if you do and you don't admit it,
we can't talk.
Okay. We can't, well, isn't
most of life not working out?
I mean this is most of the
most of life failure. I mean,
that's one of my favorite writers is
Charles Dickens or you take Shakespeare.
Charles Dickens wrote like 35 novels
of which like four or five or famous.
So He's,
well,
he's the best novelist that we've ever
produced as a species and he's got a
success rate of 20% if it shakes me,
we're one of 54 plays,
hundreds of sonnets and of his plays,
maybe 10 are regularly produce.
No, the hamlets off dollars,
motion events and all that.
So he had a success rate of about 20 so
the greatest conceivable genius is in
human history,
you have a success rate of about 20%
I've had some of my biggest
breakthroughs from failures,
from my disgust in the
failure or my discontent and
my recognizing where it went
wrong and then my reenergizing and
refocusing my standup comedy failures.
I can literally point
to the moments on stage,
like the worst bombings and
the history of my career,
and then the giant leaps that
I made and progress after that.
It's always been the case.
And I now to this day,
if I have a set that's not so good,
I recognize that I hate that.
So I will now refocus and then this is a
good thing because it's taught me well,
you got a little sloppy there or you got
overwhelmed by responsibilities or what,
you didn't put enough focus in it,
whatever it was.
Now is the time to recognize that just
like every other time in the past,
you are now going to grow and you'll
be better than you ever were before.
Yeah, I did. I didn't want to show and
I thought I did the right research,
but I didn't at all.
I did a show on healthcare and then
this woman who was a doctor, uh,
who was pretty high up in the profession,
she wrote me this long email
detailing every single thing.
But I kept running in my shell. And so
what I did was I, you know, I am like,
I just read this whole email
believe sorry. I just, you know,
I thought I knew what I was talking about.
It turns out I had to had come so far
in my ass and we see him back out of my
own eyeballs. Good on you. Yeah.
And it's a read the whole thing because
if you're not correcting yourself,
how you're going to have any credibility
because nobody believes that your ride
all the time.
That's just impossible.
I correct myself all the time on the
podcast because a lot of times during the
podcast we're completely
talking out of her ass.
I remember something and then I'll
be like, fuck. And now I go, hold on,
let me Google. Like I'll, I'll constantly
Google things when the middle I go, okay,
I'm full of Shit because actually they
proved it in 1972 that this is, you know,
and I think that's really,
really, really important,
especially when you have
this weird responsibility.
Like as I know that you do,
you have a massive following online and
a lot of people very much respect your
opinions, your thoughts on things
and consider them very highly.
So when you know,
you,
you say something or you go over something
and then it turns out that it was
incorrect or it was you,
your original assumption was
based on some bad information.
It's so important to
be flexible like that.
So important to be honest like that and
so that people recognize like you're a
human being and everyone is listening as
a human being and we're all essentially
in the same boat together.
One of us may have focused more on a
particular topic or one of us may have had
more talent in a particular area,
but we're the same goddamn thing.
No, I think, I think it is
important. And uh, yeah,
especially when you put out a lot of
chefs you can just going against that.
You can't be an expert in everything.
And that's the question
that you have to read.
And you also might want to model that
behavior for people, right? I mean,
because if you're the defensive guy
who can't admit that he's wrong,
I mean the kind of people who are going
to end up being comfortable with you are
not the kind of people you
want to have around. Oh,
this guy never admits he's wrong.
He's an okay guy for me.
Like you want to have that forcefield
that repels the people who,
who want that because
that's not a good place.
I have a very critical forum and
sometimes critical in a bad way.
Like there's a lot of congee behavior
and a lot of people just are really just
negative people.
Uh,
but a lot of really intelligent
people too that are really rely on it.
And sometimes if I have a show that
doesn't go well or if something happens or
there's a dispute about
something, Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
The criticism I think is hugely important,
especially if it's honest and it's
intelligent because that wasn't available
before.
And one of the resources of the internet
that's so fantastic to me is that you
can get opinions and you
can get intelligent ideas
from people that you would
never be able to contact with a 10 2030
years ago. You just wouldn't be able to,
and now you get them and you can
interact with them in real time.
And it's a beautiful thing and it's so
enriching and it's so important for your
personal growth and for the growth of
anything you're trying to do to have these
intelligent people giving their point
of view. You may or may not agree.
And that's one of the
things I find along the way.
Like I'll have a read it and really
intelligent review of why something that I
did was not right. And I'm like,
I see where you're coming from,
but I disagree entirely. I can
respect that, but I don't like that.
I don't like this that you're
saying is good. I don't like,
I don't like smashing pumpkins.
I don't like grateful dead.
There's a lot of things,
a lot of people like that I don't like.
Actually I do like smashing pumpkins.
Shouldn't say that both blue
skies of the songs, it was due to,
what does that one song?
I know the 79 I think.
Is there any song that I know
was that world is a vampire.
Do you know that one?
You are the person who is more of that
kind of music, I think, than I am.
I love that song.
So I shouldn't say
my temptation though. I gotta
tell you my, my weakness is a Joe.
You gotta stop me if I do this, I
want to nit pick back, nit pick back.
So I talked to a lot of libertarians
and libertarians, God loved them.
Greatest people in the world.
But if you make one factual slip,
like 6 million guys are going to come
down with you and Ricky reed references
coming down eyeballs. So at
the end of the day, I was like,
I said something about tigers
in Africa, right? You know,
and like 6 million people email me.
Do you know God?
How can you believe that there is high
cause an affricate tigers are native to
India. There's no tigers in Africa and
Africa. Completely true except goal.
No, no. Yeah. As soon as I'm like, I
bet you there's one taiga in Africa, so,
oh no, no, don't do that. When you're
rolling the wrong, I guess in Africa,
I'm with that.
Yeah. Well, you know,
people love that sport of
calling people out on the stakes.
There's a certain like scorecard that you
keep, you know, we can bust someone out.
A why or by someone on
a misquote or a mistake.
It's a, that's a big part of the deep
bumping movement. I had a guy on recently,
a guy named Mick West, uh, who's, uh,
who runs contrail science.org.
Oh, the contrail snap. Yeah.
And it's all about in his,
his website is he runs metal bunk
dot award, which is a message board.
It's all about deep bunking conspiracies
and ideas and incorrect. Awesome.
One of the things that these guys love
doing is debunking things for like a
score they like for them it's
like, you know, incorrect,
this is what's right and this is,
and they like calling people out on state,
right. It, it gives them with, oh my God,
I'm sorry. That's the wrong number
of grains of coffee for my coffee.
I've explicitly tells you the right
number. That's just off by three.
So they're right with the right,
you know,
I don't think I should be happy,
and also the level of importance of stuff.
See like I've had,
I've done write speeches about really
important stuff and make one little error
and people are like, ah. It's like you
have a big picture of people, you know,
the sun has spots. It doesn't
mean it's not like they're
right. Right, right, right.
Yeah. Oh, I just wanted to ask
you a penis knowledge. Absolutely.
And everybody felt that this
was essential, uh, to add you,
and I don't know if you
ever figured this one out,
but I watched the stuff you did.
UNCIRCUMCISION [inaudible] cause we did a,
it was Mike's idea actually. Yeah. We
did a video on, on circumcision as well,
which started off with a video of
someone getting circumcise the baby.
And it's like, if you can watch
that and still go ahead with it.
I mean already checked yourself
in against the meds, right? Yeah.
You had a question about,
because I think that the show got the
opinion that women said that the sex was
uncircumcised penis was
better. And I think you were
looking that up in the show.
And I don't know if you ever
got the answer, but we found,
I think we've found the answer, uh,
through various experimentation with it,
with fruits and veggies. I'm kidding. Um,
but what, what it is is because the, the,
the four skin, uh, has, um, it,
it makes less friction for the woman,
right?
Cause when you thrust the foreskin
has some gift, right? Right. So it's,
it's less friction for the woman. Uh,
and because it's less friction is more,
more comfortable because, you know, it's
just kind of rubbing, rubbing, rubbing.
Right. So, right.
So you trust and the four skin
has a give back and forth.
And so it doesn't stress the woman's
vagina as much through that friction.
That's apparently,
which is why I think guys who was second
inside and you need more lubricants and
stuff like that. Uh, you
know, like a good spray,
probably be 40 before you go in
or whatever. But I'm no expert.
I just want to do, as I mentioned
that and this, this, this,
it prevents aids kind of stuff. What
the fuck is that about? Yeah, I mean,
well first of all,
those studies are heavily suspect,
then rely on self reporting and stuff
like that. And secondly, it actually,
let's say it does reduce,
ate a certain amount,
which has not actually been proven to do.
It's actually kind of dangerous
because then the guys think,
well I have seven size,
I don't need a condom.
But that even if you're circumcised,
they still say, well for God's sake,
wear a condom if you want to,
if still.
So it can actually be kind of dangerous
and increase the spread of AIDS if
people believe that study. So,
so the 60% decrease in eating,
fracturing people sort of sense like,
well okay document.
So 60% are you still gonna
roll those dice? You know,
I don't need a condom because you know,
how do you,
how do you justify those numbers are,
I wouldn't love to see
how they figured that out.
It's that guy and you have a lot of
sex with a guy with aids, you know,
and then you know you circumcise him and
a well now he's even less 80 like you.
How are you doing it? Not known
for an excess of soap, right?
I mean this is really rough down
there. Right? So there's that problem.
The penile cancer thing,
I mean even the American Society of
Pediatrics because they say, you know,
you put P and l and cancer together,
you usually we'll get a man's attention.
As you know, these were like,
Hey, I wasn't listening before.
I pricked up my ears a penile. When
you added cancer to it, I really,
really began to listen. But the, the,
the numbers that go down
are so infinitesimally small
and the chances of getting
in are so teeny tiny.
I mean it's like saying well but remove
the baby's breasts because she might get
breast cancer. Like this support is
about then the support for circumcision,
the unit, almost universal support
though we find it's in America or Europe,
it's hard to find any non
Muslim kids who are circumcised.
What does it in America,
I mean it's a barbaric mutilation of a
baby's genitals as far as I'm concerned.
Yeah. I think it's some
ancient Paul Scheer removing
half the skin of the penis.
I mean it's not just the tip. I mean,
sorry, let's put it that bluntly.
And you have to put put shit
into wedge it because the, the,
the baby's born with the forced again in
here, physically adhere it to the penis.
You got to go and anyway,
we don't have to handle everything on
page details of deaths or mutilations,
which are numerous. But the idea that
it's still exists is troubling to me.
I don't, it doesn't, there's no rational,
it's not rational sense to it. There's,
there's things that I get,
I see if cause and effect and I see,
I see why people do it. I don't see
that one. I don't understand it.
The only thing that I see is perhaps a
justification of the old ways and the
fact that it's been done for so long.
It's been a style. And people say,
I want the sun to look like the dad.
And I mean,
how often a your son and your
husband comparing penises,
is that a big family hobby? I mean, we've
been at our dinner saying, well you know,
as longer and bigger. So I think, I think
a lot of it has to do with, you know,
why does trauma repeat, why does
trauma, it's a big question.
Why does trauma repeat?
And I think Ponti white trauma repeats
as it gets normalized, right? I mean,
so you obviously made the
great decision after seeing,
you already had to do normalize what
your dad did cause it hitting your mom.
I mean you,
you said like this is not how men are,
this is not how I'm going to be.
Right. So you, you normalize it.
But if you totally worshiped him and he
thought he was the best kind of ever,
and this is what men do, you would be
most likely to be enacted. Well, actually,
yeah.
Did until I saw that it was one of the
most did when I saw my dad hit my mom
when I was about five. It was the
first time I'd ever seen him striker.
And I never forgot the fee.
I mean it's really difficult to
remember exactly what I remember,
but I do remember very,
very clear feeling now.
Very feel clear feeling was,
oh he's fucked up too.
Like oh I thought that my dad was my hero.
And I remember being
massively disappointed.
I'll never forget that
feeling of disappointment.
Like this is not what I thought. I
thought my dad was awesome. Perfect guy.
And he's not at all, you know, he's a bad
person. Right. And this is a bad scene.
No mine. But why do you think you had
that response? Because some kids wouldn't,
some kids would be like, oh I can't wait
to grow up and hit my own woman. Right.
I mean why do you think
you had that response?
Cause I, cause I love my mom. You
know, my mom was not a bad person.
She was not an angry person. And when
she got all that cause it, she was,
she was a strong woman.
She is still at,
but she realized at that moment
like this is not happening.
And she packed up our
stuff and we were gone.
But I'll never forget the
feeling of disappointment.
They're like, oh, you know,
like when you're a child,
you hope that your father is a hero.
And to know that he's not.
So I think for me it was this,
this very young introduction
to close violence,
violence within the household was, um, uh,
sort of a defining factor why
I was terrified of violence,
why I wanted to learn to defend myself,
like really early on.
Like the idea that someone could just
do that to you or that someone could do
that to my wife or someone can
do that to my mother. Right?
Yeah, it is. Um, I think that kind of
recoiling from it. So you do normalize it.
It was a bad thing. I do. Do you as a
dad? I mean, I know me as a dad, I mean,
I'm the idea that I would ever see that
and look at my daughter's face or the
fall from grace. Doesn't that terrify
you? Terrifies me. I mean, I'm not like,
you know,
constantly trying to be like some statute
of perfect fatherhood or whatever,
but the idea that I would
disappoint my daughter, uh,
in that fundamental way where she have
that crossroads with me and no longer
look at me in that same, you
know, look up to kind of way.
I really think about that like every day.
I would never want to see that. I think
the love that people have for their
children often motivates them to be better
person, be a better person. I know it does
for me, you know, I, I couldn't imagine,
you know, I mean, if I even raise
my voice to my daughter, it's like,
come on, seriously, you can't do
that. We can't hit each other camp.
Throw things through a
window. You can't, you know,
the idea of hitting my daughter is insane.
It's alien.
It's impossible.
And the idea of hitting my wife is so
completely out of the idea of what's
possible.
It's,
I wonder what my feelings would be if I
didn't grow up in a house with violence.
I wonder if I wouldn't be so repulsive
to me having actually physically
experienced it in person up close.
But I did, you know, so I was,
I was inexorably the, that that's,
that's a part of my psyche,
you know, that's that, that,
that being a negative thing,
that being a horrific crime.
And there's also just a weakness.
I can never forgive a man that's willing
to do that. To hit a woman like that,
it's just so weak. It's so
incredibly, we just, it's such a,
such a failure of character and such a,
a negative,
selfish impulse to hit
someone like that. It's, uh,
you know, it's, it's one of the
major things it's wrong in, in,
in human interaction is the
ability to hurt each other too.
To want and leave,
to just reach out and injure each other.
And then he didn't express
our ignorance and such a, uh,
a violent and selfish way.
Yeah. And I, I feel that,
I'm sure you do too,
but I feel that even more strongly with
parents to kids who is so much bigger,
you know,
that your wife can,
my wife can leave me your wife and leave
you anytime. If you're a jerk, right?
Your kids can't think of no way to
go. They got, they can't just say,
well that's it. You know, I'm, I'm,
I'm getting a divorce from you dad
and I'm going to go find a better dad.
Or they have no where to go. They
have no choice. There are so tiny.
And I think mine, it's always makes you
smaller than you're a victim. You know,
and I,
I kept kind of ne four year old,
I mean you really so far out of options
as an adult with all the choice in the
world that you actually have to end
up hitting someone. So tiny dependent,
I mean that makes you
smaller than that was really some account
of a guy who was losing custody of his
child and um,
the,
the him and the wife had gotten divorced
and I was reading this articulate,
well written account of the horrors of
the legal system until I came upon this
thing where he said that his daughter
went back, the daughter was three,
went back to the wife and told of a mild
spanking that he gave her. And I'm like,
Oh, you're a douche bag. You're
aligned. Douche bag or a piece of shit.
You spank your baby.
And what you're doing here is manipulating
reality with your blog to try to
paint yourself out to be a
victim. You're fucking kid, man.
I don't care if it's a mild spanking,
you know,
mildly spank a fucking three year old
when you're a grown man. It's nonsense.
It's crazy. You don't have to do
that. They throw a temper Tantrum,
hover over them,
communicate with them until it's over
and then give them a hug no matter what.
And this is when I know it gets
frustrating. It's been fresh.
I've had frustrations and what,
that's the number one thing that
I always do when I, with my kids,
I always tell them,
when I was your age,
I was even worse at that when I was
your age. I just to lie all the time.
When I was your age, I used to do this
all the time. I always wanted to be first.
I always was selfish.
I wanted to have all the toys.
But then I realized that when you
share it toys, it makes it better.
It's hard to realize
that as a four year rule,
but one day you're going to figure it
out and that's why I'm telling it to you
and, but I have, you know, I
have a lot of time. I have a,
I'm a relaxed person.
I'm not constantly under the pressure
to perform in life and like to,
to, you know, to do better. I'm
in a good financial position.
I'm in a good relationship position.
When I see people that are stressed out
by life and then life is overwhelming in
the legs and it's like,
it's almost like they're,
they're overwhelmed by their plate
and it's terrible. I'm a child.
Yeah. I always want to my daughter
to remember that I was a kid too.
And that's what you're talking about.
I don't want her to think that I'm some
giant authority figure that is in her
life. In fact, I told her
so much about my child did,
she likes to play with me
as a kid. He goes, okay,
I want to play with little staff.
And then she wants me to come into the
room as little staff and play that way.
And I think that's great cause
I wanted you to remember that.
And I think the God, if we could
just fix language, you know,
if you can fix language,
I think we'd fix so much in the world.
There's an old confusion saying,
it says at the beginning of wisdom is
to call things by their proper names.
I hate the word bank. Just say,
yeah. You know, just say, Hey,
I hit my head a mild spank and come on.
I mean, don't call it war colon murder.
That's what it is. Spanking. Yeah. Don't
call it a rest. Call it kidnapping.
Don't call it taxation.
Call it theft. I mean,
just use the proper words for things.
And we'd solve so many problems.
Euphemisms are, you know, they just,
the plaque in the arteries of the
brain that confused so many people.
You hit your child. It's not as
banking, we say while it's mild,
it's just a little swat on the button.
Oh No, no, no. If you're spanking,
it's to deter behavior
is to change behavior,
which means the child
has to hate and fear it.
And I wish people would
just be honest about it,
but they can't even be honest
with themselves. And then
they get mad at the kids.
For me,
I agree that the categorization and this,
this,
this thing that we do where we make
one thing better than another thing,
even though it's exactly the same,
like spanking is better than, you know,
but they're the same goddamn thing.
You know? Like how about this?
I mean it's sort of unrelated,
but not really this thing
that's going on with with this,
the pouring of chemical weapons that
somehow another murdering people with
chemicals in that fashion is
way worse than using drones.
These robots that shoot Hellfire
missiles into buildings and killed 98%
innocent,
90% women and children.
There's that. Is that the actual
statistic is that 80% Jesus
there, they're so bad at
killing only the targets.
Like the idea that these
are pinpoint precise.
It's fucking terrifying shit.
But yet Obama will be on TV talking
about how these chemical weapons,
we have to deplore the of a father holy,
his children begging for them to
get up when the mother fucking kids,
you blew up from the sky.
What about rockets launched from robots
like some Orwellian nightmare flying
around cities with night vision where
someone's got a remote controller in
Nevada and they're pressing the fire
button and launching these missiles. The,
the, the, the, you know, this, this idea
that we need to take military action.
We need to kill because
people have killed, you know,
we need to go murder innocence
because innocence have been very good.
Can I Syrian? So to solve that, we're
going to kill some more Syrians,
Syrians not to kill the,
yeah.
And we're going to do it with pinpoints
strikes when meanwhile they know for a
fact they're going to move innocence
and civilians into those areas that are
high risk military targets. They're gonna
move prisoners into those, those areas.
They're going to up the body count.
You're going to do it on purpose.
And do you know,
I mean,
the terrifying thing about it's
not just the American weapons,
it's modern weapons in general is the
fact that they will fuck with entire
populations. Genetics. Like this is
something I just, I just did this, um,
study up this sort of
review the Syrian staff,
Americans outrage and chemical weapons
and neat without even getting into
Vietnam where millions of people were
destroyed by these unbelievably horrendous
weapons. The only thing America didn't
use was mustard gas and nuclear weapons.
Everything else.
They just through from Amr stand on this
population in Fallujah in 2007 they use
this white phosphorous,
which is basically just exploding the Lou
that melts human beings and they just,
it's fired indiscriminately into the
city and they use these depleted uranium
shells because they're good at piercing
armor of which there really wasn't much
of interact anyway.
But this stuff has a half life longer
than the planet itself and it's so screws
with the genetics of the
population because it goes
into the desk that goes into
the lungs have been a 600% increase in
leukemia and in the years after this
Volusia attack run by America binding
by the special forces by the army,
50% of the children were born with
birth defects. And, uh, again,
a geneticists who's kind of studied the
city says that he's never seen a more
compromised.
It's a nice way of putting it basically
more fucked up genetic population.
This is going to go on for generations.
These genes have been completely
destroyed by these weapons.
And then they're saying,
well,
you know this guy in Syria as see
he use these chemical weapons.
Then someone is like,
but at least that stuff is not going to
completely rewrite the genetic code of
the population for generations to come.
Or they deny the use of depleted uranium
even though there's a lot of evidence
that shows that they
used it in Serbia too.
I had to apologize to people because I
was talking about where they used all
these depleted uranium and all these
guys from Serbia. Right, and say what?
We don't count.
I mean come on and we will with,
they used it with us too
with the same effects
and then that's also the cross of this,
this,
this Gulf War syndrome that all these
people have come back was horrible
illnesses that mirror radiation sickness
and then the government has denied them
medical treatment, so there's
nothing wrong here. There's
something going on here.
It says
sad, sad statement that that's how we
are today. Most of the people that I
need a really nice, they just find
that to be a lot more people than I do.
They say the average famous person meets
like 10,000 people a year or some crazy
number. Right. And, but don't you
find that most of the people that you,
this is the weird thing.
The world is insane and so full of
like the most soul destroying evil.
Like yet most of the people that I meet
are unbelievably nice. It's a weird,
I mean like who are these
reptiles who run everything?
Cause I meet these really nice people
and there's all the horrible stuff in the
news. Well in all fairness, you live here.
Yes, that's true in Toronto. That's true.
I don't live a beautiful place.
Yeah,
it's a lovely place and people are
pretty nice and trying to actualize
overall I say 20% less
douchebags in Canada than America.
Well you got the BMW factor,
which we ran into a couple of times
on the drive down the BMW factory.
You know that old joke about BMW?
What's the difference?
I'm going to tell a joke to go
to a fucking line and a BMW,
the BMW and the porcupine and
the brakes are on the outside.
So other than the BMW factor,
very,
very nice people and they must bring
them in from Casa bar or something.
That's also always going to be the case
when people are privileged or when they
have more money or when they feel like
they've worked harder and the other
people are weak and lazy. You get the
fuck out of my way. I've got the Mercedes.
People love to think that the accidents
of birth, their personal virtues,
I mean then it's all, you know,
it gets a lot of, you know,
a lot of people who make it big,
you know, like put in a Poncho.
Isn't there a godfather like Steven
Spielberg or something like that.
And she's a talented actress,
a lovely lady,
but she got a bit of a leg
up in the business. Right?
But a lot of people like, oh,
you know,
I happen to be born to this great family.
I happened to be born in the west. When
you and I am born in Kenya. I mean,
what the hell are we
going to do with time?
The rubber tires to
our feet to run around.
And I mean it's so much of the good stuff
in our life is kind of accidental 100%
and you always take that
for personal virtue is a,
is a really great failing cause it
really kills your empathy. The flip side,
it's also a,
an incredible weakness that people have
when they point to successful people
going, oh they go look, you
know? Yeah, it's good enough.
If I got a funny every 10 years
you end up in a lot of lack, right.
Bust her ass and then you get lock all
the time. It's weird cause I, you know,
in your life,
of course you find here's a standup before
you got anywhere near TV or anything.
I got right. In that sense I got
super lucky cause that's really rare.
It's really rare to get on a hit sitcom
when you're five years in a stand up.
Well yes.
But I bet you when you got that Sitcom,
you work pretty hard and rough.
I got to coaching from the people who
were more experienced on the sat and you
really, really think about it
as fast as we want you to fail.
No, it's not hard. It's not an,
it's not a difficult process.
Color of all the things that
have ever done in my life.
Acting is without a doubt.
The easiest is that because it's
like other people's words and you,
you just have to be credible and
hit your mark and it's certainly,
that's a part of it, but it's also, it's
just not that difficult to just pretend.
I mean,
we all know what happens when someone
gets upset about something would all know
what happens when someone's confused.
We can pretend and it's your,
it's also when you're,
you're acting, you're, it's,
you're, you have chance to do it over
again. If you fuck it up, it's not hard.
It's coming from martial arts and
then coming from standup comedy,
those two things.
Yeah,
but you don't get to walk back and say, I
do that joke again. Maybe once, you know,
but after that, people are like, well,
he's not, he's just screwing up, man.
I got to wake up from being knocked
out and we're going to fight again.
Ice On my head.
Mulligan we do.
Right then. Not only that, it's,
it's one of those things that
when you see someone on a camera,
you see them on a screen,
see them and this weird Alpha Male,
those primate thing that we have where
we think that the person who gets to talk
especial the person that's
on camera special because
like that would be like the
leader of the tribe or something.
There's this weird,
it's the sort of hijacked
our human reward system with,
with media.
And so because of that,
when you see someone who's
on film and someone's crying,
you give them incredible accolades. You
are amazing. That film to change my life,
it was amazing. All it is, pretend
they pretending to be a murderer there.
I do what it does it for 12 hours a day.
So not hard.
Anything a four year old can do.
And I think Marlon Brando who said that,
you know, anything that four year olds,
Shirley temple, he was talking about,
you know,
anything full year old can do,
I'm not sure we should get big prizes
for watch Ricky Schroder and the champ,
it was like six years old
and he's fucking incredible.
The job like mine to sixth
sense, Dylan, hey on this,
I remember that kid just gives you
goosebumps to see. It's not hard to
do and it's not something
that requires like,
like learning to play the piano or
learning to speak French requires a lot of
brain surgery or stuff, which
is really significant. You know,
standup comedies infinitely
harder than acting.
And then granted I was
acting in a very limited way.
I was doing a sitcom, which is one
of the more limited forms of acting,
but we also created a lot of the
dialogue and effect. Dave Foley, um,
was probably responsible for maybe 50%
of everything that got made on that show.
Is that right?
He was like a secret producer because he
was such a brilliant guy and so good at
ad libbing that when he
would do is we would,
we had an amazing executive producer,
Paul Sams, brilliant, brilliant guy,
and created the show,
the head writer and executive producer
and a great writing staff as well.
But Paul was really open to us experiment.
And so he would,
they would give us a framework,
they'd give us a script,
but Dave would rewrite entire scenes.
And so,
so much of what we do on that show
was ad libbed almost maybe 50%. Right.
So it wasn't just about reading
people's lines being easier.
It's just an easier gig. It's,
it's easy. It's like, so my, um,
my stumbling into a sitcom,
it was because of a bunch of lucky
factors wouldn't lock number one that they
saw me on MTV and they
saw I got this on my,
my comedy special or be half hour comedy
hour when I was on a television show
where I did like 10 minutes.
They saw that and it went well.
And then I got these opportunities.
So just opened up from that.
And then this show came about and then
I got on it and it was a show that was
already created. So it was
all luck. That was all luck.
And the idea that you get that successful
after five years of doing standup is
really, really rare. So I
can't take any credit for that.
But then from there,
yeah, for the area and even that, I mean
to, to do the half at MTV special ed,
but it was a hell of a lot of work and
that comes out of the years on the road
and no one had to work in the audience
and the timing and what works and what
doesn't and all that.
So
that's all work. Anybody who is good at
standup, that shit does not come here. No.
No one who gets up there and can,
can kill an audience of strangers.
That's all work.
You just can't do it from the beginning.
Yeah. Anybody who gets that, you know,
lots of agro tries just, just go
give it a shot. I wouldn't, you know,
they do it once.
Maybe you will have a couple of good
lines that you've accumulated or do you
have, uh, developed over
the course of your life?
Some observations that you think are
really fun and you wrote them down.
They might be valid, they might be good.
And then my work a couple of times,
but not when people are paying, you
know, people pay 30 bucks for a ticket,
you know,
one after another.
I mean I was just amazed because the
hour and 20 that you were on stage last
night I flew by for me, you know, at
a match. Are you saying it the coach,
do you remember? It kind of flew by to
you. But I'm thinking the amount of work,
I mean the amount of material that's
written and discarded and tested and
discarded,
the amount of concentrated work that does
an hour and 20 of making people laugh.
But that's it. I mean men
typically I spoke last night,
huge amount of work entity
when I'm not working on other things.
If I'm not doing the UFC or if
I'm not working on my podcast,
I am always thinking of stuff like,
is this funny as it's interesting,
but it's also,
I've,
I've kind of designed my life in that.
The creation of material outside of
the actual sitting down in front of the
computer and writing, which is critical.
You have to, it has to be done.
That's one of the things that a lot of
lazy comedians don't do post its and
stuff like that. You can't just
do that. You have to do both.
You have to do the writing down
notes and stuff is important too.
But the actual sitting down and crafting
the bits and putting them in order and
figuring out a way you free ball when
you're on stage and let it come when it's
on stage.
Because when you're on stage you never
know what the hell can happen but this
you have to be in the moment.
Like when the guy came up to me at the
beginning of the show and handed me the
hockey puck or what
the fuck are you doing?
And then it became like five minutes
of me goofing on this guy. But it was,
I had to do it. It was this is,
this is the thing that happened.
You know this is, but it's also,
it's stitching everything together.
It's the bridges between the stories
that I was watching for last night.
How do you get from one bit to another,
and I hate the word bit cause it just
sounds like such an insignificant thing,
but that's what we call them. Yeah.
So getting logically from one,
one bit to another. Is it real? How
do you audit them? How'd you feel?
Do that. Because if you
don't, people don't want to
follow your train of thought.
The when you're doing,
when you're doing your
standard performance is not
just telling you a bunch of
jokes, but you're borrowing
someone's consciousness,
you borrowing someone's mind and the
only way it really works as if someone
trusts you enough,
your thoughts are as the there.
They're there as as they can
be. They're unique. They're,
they're surprising. They're stimulating
to the point where someone saying, okay,
take me on this rod through your mind.
Take me on this ride.
Because if you're talking like I've seen
a million comedians and there's so many
that I've seen that they start talking
and I go, okay, get the fuck out again.
I can't listen to this guys mind because
what he's doing is he's got like a one
stop. Like his premises are
short. They're, they're obvious,
they don't mail is nicely,
which is a challenge.
And there's, there's no depth
to, the thought is there's
no unique point of view.
There's nothing there.
They haven't done the work or they're not
capable of doing the work. What did we,
whichever one it is, I gotta get Outta
here cause I can't give them my mind.
You know?
Now do you want us, cause you
know, you talk about, you know,
being a positive force in people's lives
and bringing happiness and you suddenly
get that last night. Do you
want to lead the witness? Right?
Do you want people to come out
of your show better? Why Sir? No.
How do you want them to
come out of the shell?
Like it's not just having
to calorie entertainment,
that's all I would argue that you
actually do put some, you do puts,
I mean you're selling, you're intelligent
enough to put some real wisdom,
I think into what you do.
And I think that people can come out
of your shelves with some interesting
connections that they
hadn't thought of before.
I'm not saying you're an educator,
obviously,
but I think that there's stuff that
can, it's not just a burger, you know,
it's not empty calories. Right. Cause
there's a lot of thought in what you do.
Well, um, last night's
said was particularly, uh,
rich and ideas because some of the new
things that I've been working on are, um,
there's a lot of stuff that I'm working
on about the sort of a weirdness of
progressive thought later,
like this,
a really aggressive progressiveness
that's going on where people are denying
reality and they're doing it.
So because they feel like people
have been marginalized in the past,
which is true,
but it doesn't mean you spring it back
the other way and say a bunch of stupid
shit.
It doesn't make any sense.
Oh, you judge people too harshly for
judging people harshly. It's like, yeah,
how does that work? Getting people
for hit it. Exactly. Right. Exactly.
And some of the most aggressive
people I know are liberals,
so it's really strange.
I mean there's an amazing video of,
of University of Toronto,
of this guy who was speaking about
men's rights wiring foul is it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
These feminists are protesting these
students screaming in their face.
The students that want to go see
this man talk about women's Oh,
about men's rights and about
that you hate women and all this,
and they're incredibly aggressive.
Younger hate I see is in the protesters.
The only not good with, and by the way,
incredibly ignorant to what this guy,
his actual words are,
and they weren't even aware.
They didn't even bother
doing the research.
They didn't even bother formulating a
true opinion on these this guy's ideas.
They just decided that this guy
hates women and that's a weird thing.
Like I've had made some posts about
feminism on online before and one of the
things that I've found it
incredibly strange is that
I got called an Mra asshole
and so I go, what does it, what
does that mean? What's the Mra?
So that I had the events that be fighting.
I didn't know what it meant at all.
It's men's rights advocate or
an activist and I was like,
wait a minute.
A feminist,
a person who wants equal rights for women
is saying that being a man who wants
equal rights for men is an idiot.
Or I could call the Dodo and Mra
Dodo and I'm like, oh Jesus Christ.
Like love as a compressed
Socratic argument.
I could call an MRA asshole worried
toto and I didn't even know what an MRI,
I mean I'm not a men's rights advocate
by any stretch of imagination.
I don't visit any blogs,
I don't visit any forums,
but I'm a believer in equality as far
as like the laws and regulations as they
apply to human beings and I do not believe
that the laws and regulations as they
apply to human beings in this country
aren't even for men as the and women.
I don't think they're even for women
and I don't think they're even for men.
I think the three fourths laws are fucking
horrendous for men and some of them
are atrocious.
Some of them are Canada or God awful.
Dave Foley for the longest time.
I don't know if he's resolved a horrible,
anybody who's listening to this, just
Google Day Foley, Joe Experience divorce.
And there's a,
there's a youtube video that someone
compiled of just him talking about his
divorce. It will make your head spin.
And, and I know that because TV,
because what? He lost $10
million in his last divorce.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. As he said,
it's not alimony. It's all your money. I
mean, that's a, it is. It is. It's insane.
It's insane. And that's not fair. It's
not fair. I don't care what anybody says.
I think that absolutely.
If a man and woman get divorced,
the match pay child support.
Absolutely.
And if the woman was not working
during the time of the marriage,
I think there should be some sort
of compensation, something fair.
It's something reasonably,
that's some of the assets
that he developed by focusing
on whatever. Yeah, sure.
Absolutely. But there's a terrible
payments. That's just not right. It's not.
It's not right. And I have a friend who
has to pay his ex wife. Um, they were,
they were married for 12 years.
He has to pay her for the rest of
her life until she gets married.
So she plays this game.
She has a boyfriend and the boyfriend
that was of her and he sends a,
the investigators over to figure it out
and the boyfriend's not there and then
he leaves and the investigators leave in,
the boyfriend moves back in and so
he has to continue paying it like,
like she's cohabitating with a man and
he still has to continue to send her
money. And it's just a
manipulation of the legal system.
And this guy has paper millions and
millions and millions of dollars.
She's in his $4 million
Pacific Palisades home.
I mean it crippled him financially.
And on top of that he had a pay for
her lawyer, whether they want to,
it's gone through divorce and
here's where it gets really crazy.
She went to every lawyer in
town and consulted with them,
every good lawyer in town that she knew
of so that he could never use them as
counsel. Oh. Because there'd
be conflict of interest.
This is madness. I mean, she planned out,
she planned this divorce out for a
long time, was incredibly calculating.
And the idea that men don't deserve
rights and because of the fact that women
have been marginalized, which
is true, they have been.
But that doesn't mean that men
haven't been either. I mean,
human beings deserve to be treated
fairly. That's, that's true to you.
You deserve, everyone deserves to be
treated humanely. I don't believe men are,
I don't believe women are,
I don't believe humans are.
But the idea that you could separate and
be a feminist, but be anti men's rights,
well, you're a fucking crazy person
then. You know, you're not a humanist.
You're not a person who's looking at
all human beings as your brothers and
sisters. You're a person with that agenda.
You're a, a person with an ideology.
And that ideology is
that you're on a team,
you're on team vagina and everything
that's on the penis can go fuck itself.
And that was the, that
was the, the feedback.
The blow back that I got for
a joke about male feminists.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I've stepped on that landmine a
couple of times and I keep going back to
it. Cause it is, it is an important one.
Uh, you know, men in the legal system,
I mean not just the divorce,
but I mean the sentencing
disparities between men and women,
like they called it pussy pass, you
know, I mean it's, it's horrendous.
Call Feminism Marxists with pennies
because I socialism socialism,
socialism with tits.
But that was a bad character
in one of my novels.
But now I just go on the feminism,
socialism and panties.
And it's very true because I mean,
and then people call, oh my God,
that's so terrible.
It's not,
I just went through all the founding
matriarchs of the feminist system.
They're all Marxists, all
leftist and so on. And also,
if feminist is so pro woman, then
where are they with Margaret Thatcher?
Margaret Thatcher was like the
first leader of a Western country.
She struggled up from nothing.
I made him incredibly powerful woman,
but she was on the right QC. So they
hate her. What about Iran? Iran wrote,
wrote the most influential
book outside the Bible.
And the second most influential book in
according to The New York Times review
of books after the Bible, uh, you know,
reshaped a western philosophy in many
ways and western politics and the
feminists hate or why?
Cause she was on the right cause he's,
that's what they think.
She was not actually on the right but so
I mean I have these sorts of suspicions
when there is sort of the, is it the
leftist ideology or the pro woman?
Now if it's the pro woman then
they should be incredibly positive.
Where are the feminist when people
insult people like Ann Coulter,
where are the feminists? When
people insult Sarah Palin,
you know, like Bill Maher,
her called her a cunt. I
mean that's really pretty
vicious. Like publicly, openly,
right? I mean where are the fee because
they're on the rights and cultural are
considered to be on the right. So they
get a pass where people go, you know,
but you then say something
bad about a woman on the left.
And so I think that it is more left
than it is pro women because when they
choose between their
politics and the gender,
they always seem to choose
the politics over the agenda.
And that's why I say it's left
as rather than than pro woman.
I agree.
And I think there's,
there's a lot of really emotional and
non objective thinking attached to
feminism and there's a lot of, there's a
lot of really strange. The, the, the, the,
one of the more ones that I find
incredibly strange is this,
uh,
there's this new trend of accusing men
of rate if they have sex with a woman
who's had something to
drink. This is a, uh, like a,
a broad sweeping thing that's going
through the Internet. And a lot of these,
uh, it's really weird because it seems
to be, there's a lot of it in this,
what they call a skeptical community.
And I,
the skeptical community
seems to be integrated with
a lot of male feminists and
feminist. And this is something that
they've adopted this idea that somehow,
or another skepticism and this idea,
uh, that they, that they combine.
And it's,
I don't know if you're aware of the
case that Michael Shermer thing you know
about all about cues to some
significant sexual impropriety, right?
No evidence other than a person who
doesn't want to reveal their name.
Who He, the guy who wrote the piece
heard about second hand. Yeah.
He didn't even hear about
it directly from the person.
And this is the person
who's supposed to validate.
They not see like I don't understand is
it makes it, yes, he's getting sued now,
but it's the idea of that
being the skeptic community.
I mean one of the things you learn as
a skeptic when you're breaking down any
idea, whether it's a religious idea
or whether it's an idea about a,
an event that took place is that a
person's eye witness account of any
individual event is suspect and
that it's one of the worst forms of,
of evidence.
And it doesn't mean that a terrible
thing didn't happen with this person,
but it does mean that if you look at the,
in the context of the way it was explained
in this guy's blog is that she was
put in a position where she
couldn't consent. Like what?
What kind of Weirdo language is that?
And then the,
the corroborating evidence that he uses
in this blog is that a woman went to a
party with this guy and he kept giving
her drinks and he was flirty and that she
got drunker than she usually does.
And that's it.
That's the corroborating piece of evidence
that the man and a woman who are both
adults were drinking together
and she got drunk. I mean, I,
you talk about removing yourself
from personal responsibility that he,
this guy was responsible for you
getting drunker. Like that's insane.
Like that's insane for a person
to say this, then we'll be drinks.
What choice did I am a
feminist? Like, why would you,
how is it possible that a person who
believes in the power of being woman could
think that a woman is so
much weaker than a man?
That she can't control how much liquor
she consumes when she's around a man,
but the man somehow or another,
by being with her and drinking with her
forces her to consume what you normally
would. That's madness. And there's
no excuse called I was drunk. I mean,
try that with drunk driving, right?
It's the whole point. Is that okay? Yes.
You had diminished capacity
while you were driving,
but you were responsible for
drinking and getting in the car.
It's the one time when we're willing to
alleviate someone of their own personal
responsibility and only women.
A man is more of a man who,
if a man and man is more responsible,
a man of women are dropped together.
But the woman, uh, it feels bad
about the encounter in the morning.
The man raped her leaving.
All the man was drunk as well.
But the men are always the aggressors
and always therefore guilty.
I mean that's not humanism,
but that has taken, and this
is a long dock road, uh,
that as a man and you know,
I'm sorry that if you're a woman,
it's really hard to get this.
We have had so much negativity over
the past 40 or so years paroled and
masculinity that, I mean, we were like
half criminals just for breathing. I mean,
if you look at the, the role models on
TV, how, how men to portray, you know,
the homeless Simpson's and the
American dads and that they take,
we're all just idiots and sex
craze and irresponsible and stupid.
And the amazing thing is that it's true.
Then if you look at the bell
curve of intelligence for women,
it's kind of spikes in the middle.
So many more women are of
average intelligence than men.
Now you still have your brilliant women,
you still have your done with it.
But if you look at the bell curve
of male intelligence, much flatter,
which means that we have a
lot more geniuses and lot
more complete idiots, right?
And what's happened is everybody's
focused on the idiots among men.
And I've completely began to ignore all
the brilliance that men bring to the
world. All of the amazing, incredible
inventions that men bring to the world,
and it's just we're focusing on this
low cluster, which is incredibly biased.
It's like saying, okay,
what blacks in America,
they commit more crimes and we're just
going to focus on that and say that's all
the black are and that's all
we're going to portray as blacks,
as criminals and blah, blah,
blah. Would we incredibly racist,
but the sexism of portraying men as
idiots because we happen to have more
cluster as a gender on that side and
completely ignoring all of the incredible
stuff that that brilliant
men bring to the world.
It's incredibly sexist and it's really
hard for, for for people to see.
I mean like the idea that
you were talking earlier,
the idea that a woman can competently
raise children without a man around,
it's just taken for granted.
Now it's absolutely not true.
Men are essential to the
healthy raising of children,
but the idea that we would
recognize that as a society,
it's just we were just the disposable.
It's also a very unfortunate situation
went in in regards to feminism that uh,
a lot of people are dealing with their
own personal experiences that they've had
with a few asshole men in their lives
in regards to them not being sexually
attractive or not fitting into
a certain social group or not.
And then they have somehow or another
extrapolated that that all men are pieces
of shit and rapists or a massive amount
of them need to be curved and laws need
to be changed. And if you get drunk
with a girl and you have sex with her,
you were a rapist, right? I mean,
and a lot of this is based on their
own negative interactions with men.
And the stereotype of feminism
unfortunately is like,
there's a meme online, this is
feminism. And it's a woman who, uh,
has a, um, a, uh, of, of,
of political holding up a sign saying
I'm a feminist and she's fucking 300
pounds. And you know, and everyone's like,
yeah, that's feminism. You know, like,
this is, yeah, you're right. It's a big
fat, ugly girl that no one's a fuck.
That's really unfortunate.
But the, the type of person
that is a large, unattractive
woman is going to deal with and uh,
in measurably,
it's going to be so much harder for,
for her to find people who
are sexually attracted to her,
for her to find a healthy
relationships for her too. If you,
it's an unfortunate reality in this
world is that if you are not sexually
attractive,
you are not going to have as easy ride
when it comes to the opposite sex.
It's just a fact.
Well, I mean, but sexually
attractive and 300 pounds, I mean,
somebody who's 300 pounds is for
most people are going to be sexually
unattractive, but if they
shouldn't lose weight and exercise,
that's sort of a different matter.
And that just comes down to
a basic human competence.
But one of the things
that I've thought of,
like I grew up with a single mom and we
lived because single moms who used to be
broke, right? I mean,
because it's a test life.
And so when I grew up with a single mom,
everyone around me has single
moms as well. You know,
what's interesting is that the kind of
men who float through single mom world,
they're not always the best kind of
men, right? They kind of trashy, right?
Because like the really
competent and successful and
intelligent men on trawling,
the girlfriend froms at the single mom,
you know,
they'll rent housing getups right,
right.
And so I think what happens is a lot of
these women have grown up in single mom
households or, or in this sort of
environment. And Sue who would,
the men who floating through that,
they tend to kind of be losers.
They tend to be pretty unstable. They
tend to be kind of parasitical. They,
you know, they don't tend to be very, the
very best specimens of, of masculinity.
And so I think the breakdown of the
family has created an environment where a
lot of girls growing up don't have a
positive male role model in their life.
And the kind of end that they see floating
through their mom's bands tend to be
kind of trashy. So they're
like, well, this is masculinity.
It's also very unfortunate that
in a criticism of masculinity,
you've removed a lot of allies.
You know,
by by blanket generalizations of men,
you removed a lot of people like myself
who I can't support you on that even
though I'm the entirely approach
human being and, and pro equality.
But when you make these
mass generalizations and
call someone a men's right
advocate asshole like that, these,
these are nonsense statements.
And it's unfortunate that
I guarantee you these,
and it's not saying that all feminists,
feminists or unattractive or all
feminists or uh, you know, uh, not, not,
not sexually viable,
but I guarantee you almost all of them,
I've had a lot of negative
experiences with men.
And it doesn't mean that
all men are negative.
And it doesn't mean that there's not
people out there that you would assume
would be assholes, are actually very
nice people. But you've got this, uh,
this idea that's,
it's easier to define the world by these
rigid dimensions that you've sort of
set up for yourself.
And when I,
when I read things that are from
this feminist point of view,
there's so often aggressive and it's so
often, and I get that there's a blowback.
I do get that I get
that they've experienced
marginalization and they believe
that,
you know,
society is set up to support rape culture
and all these strange ideas and that
there's a back to it. But I don't think
that the way it's being handled is,
I think it's, I don't think
it's objective. I don't,
I don't think it's rational and I
don't think it's balanced. And, uh, I,
I find it really weird when
really intelligent people
have attached themselves
to these feminist ideas.
Yeah. And, and, but the problem
is, you know, in Canada here,
I had a guy on my show, a great game,
Bill Gehringer who wrote, um, uh,
the end of the family and what it was,
and he pointed out that there's
a revolution that occurs.
I think that initially is necessary.
And I think this is also
with Latin America too.
There's a revolution that occurs
that is initially necessary,
but the whole point of a revolution is
to defund itself to end, right? So yeah,
I mean there was stuff that needed to be
done. Obviously we've talked about the,
certainly with blacks in the 60s and some
stuff with women's kind of different,
right? So cause women, there's always
been this women and children first, right?
Like the vast majority of the
people who died at the titanic,
we're men offering up their
lifeboats to women, right?
Cause there has been a sort of women and
children first and women have been kind
of elevated. There was no black people
for us in the south right there.
So it's a little bit different.
But there was,
I think some push for quality
that needed to happen.
But then what happens is you get a lot
of people who get heavily invested in
this course and the becomes
their ego, their identity, right?
Like I fight for black wives,
I fight for women's rights and so on.
But then what happens is
society will often listen and
respond in a positive way.
And then what happens is that course
begins to diminish and people are like,
you know,
supporting like,
I'm not going to support
to the abolitionist cause
because slavery is ended,
like I just not tend to do it
and it's over, right? I mean,
there may be other problems, but that's
not the problem, right? Like ours,
I don't to support a lot
of, uh, you know, let's,
let's deal with polio victims because
we've got this vaccine and we don't really
have polio victims anymore.
Right?
So the whole point of a
revolution is to defund itself,
to end for people to
move on with their lives.
But what happens is when
you have government,
you get these voting blocks and you get,
like in Canada,
over the last 10 or 15 years,
Katie government's given $300
million to feminist groups.
That's not coming from Canadian women
or Canadian men for that matter.
Because you know,
a lot of it's kind of been dealt with.
But these groups continue by by poking
these scabs and by continuing these
grievances and my finding the Trayvon
Martin situation and blowing it up into a
race war. And all this kind of stuff.
A lot of the stuff has been dealt with,
but because the government's still given
the money, they still need to work up.
These kinds of hysteria is there
just to justify their own existence.
I mean the whole point of
a revolution is to end.
The whole point of I want to deal with
measles is get a vaccine and end measles,
you know, keep taking the same
amount of money that year after year,
but if you have a government funding it,
then you have to manufacture
these grievances,
which just keeps things
going and getting worse.
The point of revolution as a resolution
and this resolution
never seems to come play.
It's never going to take place if your
approach is imbalanced and there's just
some things that are being some proponents
of feminism or endorsing one of them
being the ability to withdraw
consent equals rape. The ability to,
you mean after the fact
it's after the fact. Yeah.
That's sending you consented to be giving
you my coffee and then charging you
with theft when you walk out the room.
Yeah. Take my coffee. Oh, officer,
he stole my coffee because I changed
my mind after the fact when he left.
Well,
the idea is that a man can lie to a
woman in order to get in bed with her and
then if she can prove that he did that,
that she,
that he's a rapist because he
tricked her with his words.
Yeah, because of course we're going to
have a lie. I mean they don't use makeup.
They don't puff up their tits.
They don't ever falsify any of their like
a man because he's wealthy and hope to
get
pregnant with the music.
I mean,
I don't see any feminists that
are the crime that, and that's a,
that's a horrible front to womanhood.
The think that the only way that you could
make a live in is to lie to a man and
make him get you pregnant so that you
can get money from him. From then on.
I mean, feminists, true feminists
should be horrified by that.
It was all focus on the false rape
accusations, false rape accusations,
which in some studies are 2030 or
40% of the study in the air force.
But they actually, even women who
have withdrawn their accusations,
2030 or 40% of rent,
rent accusations in some studies,
who knows what it is universally
are our false. I mean,
how horrendous that and women
should be coming down so hard.
I'm women who make false rape accusations
cause they make it so much harder for
the women who actually happen,
right?
Because then there's that
problem or a false paternity.
And the problem with false rape
accusations are very few women face
repercussions for them.
Now in my book, if you can,
if you accuse someone of a crime and
you lied, you get the punishment,
they would have gotten you shit.
How it shaped green.
This football player who has recently
been released, uh, he got on tape,
this girl a admitting that she lied
about him being him raping her and her
family received $1 million
or $850,000 and now they,
you know, they, they have
to pay the money back.
But that's the extent of her punishment.
This guy went to jail for
five fucking years, you know,
and now he's just trying to read, pursue
report. He'd still be there. Well,
not only that,
he's just one of many.
I have three friends that
were falsely accused of rape.
I also have friends that were raped. I
know that there's, I know rape is real.
You know, I have friends who've
have been roofie and you know,
got out of danger because someone
recognizes the hadn't been drug. It's,
it's very common. You
know, rape is a disgusting,
Horrible Anti Human Crime
and I think rape is,
should be treated the same
way as murderers. You're,
you're denying someone
their humanity you're doing,
you're taking away something,
some part of them,
you're removing a part of the w
who they are as a person that's
kind of permanent. Yeah. Somebody,
you can get a new car, but there's
something about sexual violation,
but it's kind of a permanent,
it's horrible, but so is lying about
it. That's horrible to lying about.
A rape is just as hard a lot of it. But
often we get a man, right? Yes, yes.
And this idea of this idea
of withdrawing consent,
you know,
and that somehow or another you could
do that and turn a guy into a rapist.
That's, that's like hating thing
that's, uh, you don't, you,
you know what you're doing
is you're, you're, you're,
you're hating someone who's manipulative.
You're hating someone
who can con you into bed.
But that's been what men have been
trying to do since the beginning of time.
Like you're heating of the
game of courting a woman.
And there have been men that wear shoes
that they would never wear and watches
me would never buy.
And cars,
they don't give a shit about an apartment
that they decorate just to get the
woman to believe that they're like
this. It's all alive. My friend Brian,
we saw earlier tonight, last
night for sure. Um, Brian
Callahan, so hilarious guy,
the first time that came over his
house back when he was single,
he had Jack Kerouac on the road
sitting on his night table opened up.
And I, you know, I'm a Predator,
so I came over his house. I'm like,
did she may have written
that? You know, I,
I find weakness that people very
quickly. So I saw that. I go,
you're not fucking reading that.
I go, you're, you're hoping to.
Chick comes over and she sees
that and she's like, Oh, you read.
So polling are amazed that he's
there. He started laughing. He goes,
true, true. I decorate my house to
pretend I'm smarter than I am. I did that.
There was a Stephen Hawking book, a
brief history of time or whatever, right?
And I had that on my desk and this woman,
I loved her to death.
We went out for a while. This woman came
over and she's like, I call bullshit.
I call bullshit on stuff later. And I'm
like, no, no, no. I've read it. And she,
what she did is she went over and she
opened it and it creates like an old boat
and it never made it open before.
And it didn't go into his spine was
completely unvetted. They're like,
you know what?
You got me.
That's nurses. That's hilarious.
We lie, we pretend, you know,
I've always,
I have this thing and I say people,
and I think a lot of times we lie and
pretend it was a big part of us because
we're not happy with who we are,
where we're not really and we like to be.
We would like to wish that we were
somewhat better. I always tell people,
be the person that you pretend to
be when you're trying to get laid,
you are your life optimally.
You want to really be an admirable person.
Be The hero of your own story and be the
guy that you pretend to be when you try
to get laid and if you can find people
who love you for who you are. I mean,
my God, isn't that easier? Yeah. The
problem with the pretenses, you know,
it's fine in the moment, but man,
you've got to keep that shit up.
That's a lot of work and you have to
love yourself to, in order to be loved.
If you have all sorts of flaws that you
don't fix and you don't like various
aspects of yourself that you
don't correct what normal person,
they're normal and they're,
they're, they're sensible.
Mine would want to engage in a
longterm relationship with some of this
incredibly flawed knows it
and does nothing about it.
Like that sounds like a nightmare.
That's how like taking out
a dog that shits all over
the house, you know, you're,
you, you, you're just taking out a giant
problem. You gotta fix this person.
And some people do do that. They take
on projects, you know what I mean?
I have a friend who every
fucking girlfriend and dates,
it's always broken and that he can never
see that your problem is your own life
is a mess and you don't
want to deal with that.
So you bring people into your life that
are more fucked up and you could fix up
some of their problems. Advice,
yeah. We constantly give them advice.
So you're going to fix them,
but fixing yourself, bitch.
And if you did fix yourself, you
wouldn't want these people in your life.
If I did a 300 pound woman, the fact
that I'm to 80, it looks better.
So I don't have to diet. I look
smaller right next. Her. Yeah. I mean,
I think that that is a huge part of w
what's wrong with people in relationships?
What's wrong with a lot of people
in relationships is internal.
It's what's wrong with you?
What are you bringing into a relationship
until you are happy with who you are
until you're, you're,
you're, uh, just a, a,
a reasonable person who's objective about
your own actions and objective about
your own path in life and
enjoying your own path in life.
You're not worthy of a healthy,
happy relationship.
You haven't gotten your own shit
together yet. Wow. This is terrible.
I think dichotomy where,
you know,
women get married to guys hoping that
they'll change and you guys getting back
to women hoping that they wound, you're
not going to cut that long hair. I,
you like when you have kids,
right? I mean, you're going
to keep exercising, right?
You're still going to look right.
Right. And, and all that. And I mean,
the idea that you're with someone
in the hopes that they'll change,
it's just completely insane.
It's like buying a Buick and helping.
It's going to be a boat. I mean,
it's not what you bought it.
Them thinking about
bogus, ridiculous. Well,
there are a lot of women
who like to do that though.
They would like to fix fixing change
definitely at him and he's going to be
right. It's a throw things out. Like,
where's that, where's that book?
I shouldn't read that.
Or, or you know, there's still three
Adams holding my underwear together.
How dare you put them in the garbage.
I have a friend and uh,
his, uh, girlfriend, uh,
he went to the bathroom and his girlfriend
was confronted by my other friend's
girlfriend about the kind
of car he drives cars.
He drove a sports car and he had a
Ferrari. He's a wealthy guy. And the,
the girlfriend was like,
why don't you let him drive that car?
He let him drive that car.
That was her words.
Like your guy driving a car like that.
It's like, you know, he's like, he's like,
why do you let them have that college?
She was correcting him because she was
concerned that her boyfriend might get
ideas. Like I can get a car like
that too because my friend has a dog.
So she wanted to,
what?
She was worried about her and
she did it in front of her man.
I like to check him.
She went to this girl and was correcting
her situation of a fucking car.
I mean it was like decisive.
You've got time.
Don't you have shit to do with
your life rather than a woman.
Trouble them manipulate.
And she was incredibly
manipulative. This woman and uh,
you know those,
those people are not in my life anymore.
But this woman was incredibly manipulative
and she, she would, the guy was like a,
a wealthy, strong guy.
But for whatever reason,
this attractive woman came in and was
life and just started dominating him.
She didn't work.
I paid for everything and she
wouldn't let him do shit. She,
she chose everything that he did.
She dressed him.
She bought clothes for him and he
was not allowed to buy a sports car.
She not as anything great
about having a sports car.
But I don't understand if
you're going to be a capitalist,
you've gotta be a materialist, which
they clearly worry this big giant house.
She would buy whatever
the fucking car you want.
If you're really going to bust
your ass and work 12 hours a day.
I'm not saying there's any great honor
or no ability and buying a Ferrari,
but if you really want a Ferrari and
you've got a lot of money by a fucking
Ferrari,
who gives a shit
that reminds me best moment into
Peter Joseph interview because I'm,
we're doing it. I'm doing a debate
with him on Monday. Ah, cause uh,
we have slightly different ideas about
how the future should go and we'd have a
debate and as I listened to your,
uh, your, your show with it,
which is really enjoyable and I love
the, where he said, you know, you know,
they, they could make better
cars, you know, like the Ferrari,
they could make that
better. And you're like, no,
they absolutely could not make that
car any better than it is anyways.
With something like that was like,
I mean,
that's the pinnacle of human engineering
to shut the fuck up. Yeah. Like, I mean,
unless you're going to have like an
angel's wings and wheels that you cannot
improve that car.
That's about as good as you get sort of
silly socialist ideology where you don't
vet your facts out before
you start blabbing. You know?
You can't say they can make
them better Porsche. No,
they fucking race the 24 hours a la Mons,
they competing as the
best cars in the world.
They brilliantly
engineered these vehicles.
Guys know the uptake from the Porsche is
the fucking teleporter and stuff. Right.
There's no better way to get
around that when people talk. Yeah.
To me like that, like they can make
a better car. No, they cannot stop.
You don't know what you're talking about.
You don't know the history
of what you're saying.
What you're doing is saying something
that goes along with your ideology.
You would like it to be true because
it would make you more brilliant.
Good, make your points. But if I have
to bend facts to meet your theories,
that exit of brilliant. Right. It have
to be a slave to the facts. Right.
He's got it.
Great thing going on.
He's got a really interesting thing
going on but it's very culty you know is
there's a lot of, there's, there's a
lot of cultiness to that and it's also,
it all falls out the window
when you realize that he's
a stockbroker. He was for,
he still does still does it. So he makes
his money. Really? Yes. He's a day trader.
It doesn't,
you get people to like rip out their
kidneys and emailed them to him or
something that isn't that what the cedars,
it's unlikely the guy trying to run a
call if he's a very smart guy and I don't
think he believes he's
sort of a frustrated
musician and a day trader.
Yeah. Very bright guy and
Moxley play the stock market and mocks
bank has made and then it kicked her out
when she had a baby. Cause
you know exploiting the
working classes is really bad.
Right, exactly. It just kind of
do it as well as the capitalist.
That's my problem.
There's a lot of those guys out there
that become intoxicated with the attention
that you get from having good
ideas, you know? And that's a,
that's a real common
occurrence and human nature.
Whenever someone gets to talk and people
listen and go, you're amazing. You just,
you know, oh, I'm amazing. You don't
go, hmm. Does that person just dumb?
Maybe like I need, I need more of you
all, all the smart people out the room.
I even move you and your second cousins,
especially if you've bred together,
bring me your children.
They'll just fit right in.
I'm always the first point out that
every single thing that ever comes out an
office,
essentially just some things that I've
read and you've very humbled about that.
And you opened, he said like, I'm
not smart enough to understand this.
I don't really get that, but she's in my
thoughts. And that is important. Yeah.
Cause I mean, nobody has the answers the
best. I mean, I like what Socrates did.
The best you can do is provoke thought.
I mean,
how many answers have we given the people
in this conversation? Not really. Well,
don't get your kids, you know,
that's one reason with your kids,
maybe you stay home with them if
you can then he of anyway, but,
but those are sort of,
I mean that's such common sense that the
fortunate or unfortunate put me but big
answers, you know, man, I think the oldest
really worried about that. You know,
the moral instructors of mankind and
usually complete control freaks and
ourselves
Senate grey,
I think it's almost impossible.
I think we all together can work things
out by talking and exchanging ideas and
exchanging opinions and agreeing and
seeing each other's points of view.
I think we could help that way
we can all help each other.
But the idea that one person is going
to be the more moral authority or the
voice of Wisdom,
it's a very dangerous position.
It really is.
I been,
there's a few things that are
uncomfortable saying people shouldn't do,
but outside of that,
I have no idea what is going to make
you the happiest in life. I mean, yeah,
don't steal. Don't kill dunk.
Right, fine, fine, fine.
But even how many people really
do that? Not many. Right?
But actually how people should
live. I mean, man, if it doesn't,
we can start pointing guns at each other
and we can stop having these crazy laws.
Stop throwing people in jail for
the wrong bits of vegetation.
I think that would be a
great step forward. You know,
let's just stop pointing
guns at each other, gets get
stuff done. Outside of that,
I have no idea what people should
do to make themselves happy.
And if that's you're
legitimately intelligence and
half the time I'm not even
sure myself, right? I mean,
you sit there and say, well,
what should I do with my day that's
going to make me the happiest?
It's nice to have to try so whatever.
Right?
But as to what other people should do,
you know,
who they should be with and what
careers they should follow. I mean,
that's really, it's impossible. It's
hard to know. It's a very important,
yeah,
you bring up that.
Especially because there's so many
things that people like that I don't,
there's so many things that I liked the
people don't like. I've had a really,
really intelligent friends that go,
why do you like this mixed martial arts
stuff? I don't know. I just do. I like it.
Did I know, I understand that
it's, it's a controlled violence.
I understand that it's a,
it's a disturbing for some
people to watch, but to me,
it's been a part of my life since
I was a boy. And, uh, I, you know,
I find it incredibly fascinating. Sorry,
you don't, it's okay. You know, you know,
and by the way,
the people that I've met that are
mixed martial artists are fighters,
are some of the nicest people
I've ever met in my life.
And one of the reasons is that they've
conquered their ego to a certain extent,
and that they have a much better control
over it because they're being checked
over and over again on a
daily basis in the gym.
Oh, discipline is highly
underrated. Virtue.
I think it used to be more
highly rated discipline. I mean,
the discipline to say when you're
wrong, you're wrong. I mean,
that's what bothers me
so much about people.
It's this lazy edges of their permission
slips. You know? Like I was like,
when people do like really stupid
shit out of me, it's just like how,
how has that, how do you give yourself
permission to do that? Like how has that,
how was that on your list of possible
things to do and still be happy about
yourself or, or even like how has
that, you know, you know, I hit my kid.
How is that? Like how was that
even on your list possibilities?
How do you have, like, why
would you just say, no,
I'm not going to do that and
have the discipline to not do it.
That seems to be pretty obvious.
It's very underrated aspect of being a
man of being a human is having a code
that you live with.
Yeah, some self discipline. Like,
I mean the guys would get up at 5:00
AM workout and stuff like that. Like,
you know, the other day I was like,
yeah I can be like most people are like,
oh I'm kind of tired trying
to work out or having that,
you know and you know part of you's like,
oh what an app would be nice
right now because she's like,
yeah go do a word better feel better and
just sleep better that night cause you
didn't have an happen scrub your cycle.
So just that kind of discipline is,
is really lacking.
I think we used to have a lot more of
it when we were really confronted with
nature a lot more.
And how will you live in this fuzzy city
where you can get everything 24 seven
it's all easy to come by and so on.
And we've got kind of,
and the material listen to me comes
with the laziness and the lease.
And this comes with the depth because
we talk about national debts and so on.
I mean in,
in America and to some degree is almost
as bad in Canada to people like have
debts and way bigger than their income.
And that's a kind of laziness too. Like,
what's with the different, like why not
the first and gratification, you know,
they're gonna study on kids.
It's called the marshmallow study.
They take four year olds and
they sit them down and they say,
you can have two marshmallows now.
Sorry, you can have one. You can't, you,
you can have two marshmallows now or you
can have for marshmallows if you have
to. If you have one now and wait,
they're always take two now. Well No,
there's some of them that that will
differ real and there's some of them that
won't and they track these kids through
life and they find that consistently
those were able to defer gratification.
Just do a hell of a lot better.
I bet you there were times when you got
up to do fear factor and you're like,
if there's one thing I don't want
to do today, it's fear factor,
but I mean the discipline to just
get up and you know what I mean?
What Woody Allen says, you know,
90% of success is just showing up.
That's kind of the discipline to do
it when you don't feel like doing it.
Then deferral of gratification.
I'm sure with the training there's
times with the address kicked butt,
you'd pull the muscle and just like,
well, I'm going to go back and do it.
Or there's times where like that
she's getting looks like I'm,
well I'm drooling like a tsunami here,
but you just don't do it.
And I think that kind of discipline.
Um,
so you said that the fibers
are like really great guys.
I think it's because they
probably would've worked
that muscle of discipline to
the point where they have a code,
they have a set of personal
responsibilities and they
don't let themselves step
outside of that.
And so there's a kind of security and
people who have a lot of discipline in
whatever field it is that
they're working in. A,
I really like being around people who
have got a lot of discipline because you
know, they're not just going to
do some random shit. It's awesome
firing to me. Yeah. I like being
around people that work hard. It's,
it makes me feel like I should get things
done to accomplish things and people
accomplish things around you
and they're, they're, they've,
they've experienced joy and success and,
and they experience this feeling of,
wow, I did it. I pulled it
off. That's inspiring. It
makes you want to do the same.
It makes you want to and the more things
I accomplished and the more things I do,
well the happier I am as a person
I find as a direct correlation.
Do you have a, a plan that, I know you
said you was, it's a little bit, you know,
grab what you can and as far as your
career goes in a little on the lesson plan
side, but do you have a sort of an
idea of what you want to go five years,
you know, 10 years kind
of thing? Um, no, no,
I uh, I'm here, this sort of,
yeah, while I'm here, you know what I'm
doing right now. I love, I really a,
I like to keep doing it and my plan
is to continue to do it. But if I,
if everything maintained
exactly where it is right now,
I don't think I would
do anything differently.
I think it would continue
to work on my standup.
I continued to do a
commentary for the fights.
I've continued to do podcasting
and I enjoy all those very much.
I continue to try to be the best father
I can continue to try to be the best
husband I can, all that good
stuff. But other than that,
no, I don't have any plans,
my plans or just enjoy life.
And I enjoyed life very much.
My plans were to maintain that
enthusiasm and that happiness,
the joy of life.
Uh,
and it spread as much of that as I
can inspire people if I can. And, uh,
and it just inspired
people by enjoying myself.
How's other people have inspired
me by enjoying their lives. Um,
I'm inspired constantly by
people love their craft,
like people who love their profession,
but people love what they do is so it's
very infectious, you know? So that's,
that's the only girls in our house.
And that's,
I mean,
that's sort of the definition of a happy
life that if it continues the way it is,
that's pretty damn good.
Yeah.
Yeah. And you know, and maybe grows
and maybe, uh, maybe gets some,
I would like to get better and
everything that I'm doing that I enjoy,
but you have to, I, in Jujitsu, you
don't maintain to get better. And comedy,
you don't maintain,
you get better.
If you continue to focus on it
and you learn from your, your,
your past experiences,
you're going to improve.
If you apply intelligence
and focus to anything,
you're going to get better at it.
There's,
it's not like you can become a master
at comedy, even if you are a master,
you know, you call yourself a black belt.
In comedy, there's, there's, there's room,
there's always room. This room in
Jujitsu, there's room and martial arts,
there's room and everything.
I left the disciplines with no limits.
But you can't ever say this is the end.
It's never ends. There's no, there's
no like, you're never a total master.
It's not possible. I mean,
you, you can teach and you,
you will have a certain amount of math.
Like there's certain moves that I
cannot teach someone in Jujitsu,
but could I teach you Jujitsu mastery?
Yeah.
Something you have to like sort of
pursue on your own and most likely you'll
never achieve.
You might have a master,
you might be masterful over
one particular skill level,
but then someone else come along that is
much more skillful than you and master
you. You know, it's, it's,
it's a constant series of
levels and it's fairly infinite.
And then there's also, you know, the
physical challenges and, uh, you know,
athletic ability and all
sorts of intangibles that
different people bring to the
equation. But I think that
in pursuit of those things,
it's where you find yourself and
that they're, they're really, uh,
the interesting aspects of it is the,
the growth that you
achieve in those things,
whether it's through the growth in
writing comedy or anything difficult,
those things manifest itself,
manifest themselves in the
rest of your life as well.
You get better at everything.
Yeah.
I sort of asked you,
is there a dream guest fear
podcasts that we cannot if he was alive,
he had his brother on a fascinating guy.
Um,
the Dreamcast I think I've
already had, you know, I, I
would like more of the same.
You right. Neil degrasse
Tyson was great. Um,
he's one charismatic guy,
you know,
it's great to have someone in
front and center, rational thinker.
We're putting it out to the masses,
that beautiful
Mainer team from tools. Great.
Graham Hancock's, but so
many great guests. I just,
I just, I enjoy doing it.
I enjoy talking to people,
but I think it's,
it's broadened my perspective immensely
to be able to have these kinds of
conversations like you and I sitting
down here for hours just chatting.
I think that's a, it's really difficult
to pull off in the real world, you know?
Yes.
We're agreeing to have a podcast.
It's really hard to just set aside three
hours where we're just going to talk.
It's hard.
Oh, it's an incredible privilege. I mean,
I feel incredibly fortunate to have the
opportunity to have conversations like
this or other people I do.
On my show. I mean, you know,
but it's going to be a dad.
I got all the parenting experts in
the no university come on my show.
It was like, Ooh, you know,
so I get to learn it. How do
people get to learn? I mean,
it's an incredible privilege and this
technology that makes it possible and then
he's amazing.
It's fantastic.
Yeah. They're like, look how
little we're using here. I mean,
you have a camera set up and
thank goodness you have them.
I could record verse 27 minutes.
We didn't even get this and
that was the gold stuff,
but this is just a little piece of,
you know,
electronics and it's plugged
into the wall and that's it.
And maybe a million people here.
This molded,
it goes in the world for ever more harm.
More than a million really?
Because each one of my downloads is over
half a million. Right. At the minimum.
1 million. Can we start again then?
Because I was seeing like a little rusty,
but is that how many times you've been
there, a standup comedy show before? Oh,
I used to do a lot.
I mean,
I used to go to a lot when
I was in the business world,
we'd have clients come up and I'd always
want to take it to a comedy club cause
it sure beats a movie. Right? And
so I used to go see a lot of comedy.
I did a little bit, you know, just some
amateur shit when I was uh oh you did?
Yeah. So and uh, yeah, just open like
stuffing, it wasn't really my thing,
but uh,
it was fun to go up and try.
I was like doing that sort of stand on
the cliff edge thing. Uh, but I, uh,
I love stand up. I think, I think
what you guys do is like fantastic.
I think it's just a real ray of sunshine
in human like, and what you give is, is,
is you give permission for people
to be, to be funny themselves, to,
to have fun and the
joy that you guys have.
The one the things I love most about
stand up and you know the breaking bit,
and you did it a couple of times last
night where you did something that's so
funny that you yourself found it funny
because maybe it was unrehearsed or
something spontaneous,
or you had a thought because that's
seeing somebody who have joined the moment
is really, really enjoyable. If it's real,
that's not really all I know.
There's some people that do like fake
breaks or they'll laugh at their jokes a
fucking billion times in a row and every
time you see them they'll laughing at
the same way.
It's kind of gross.
But last night I was working
on a bunch of new stuff,
so that was one of the reasons why I
thought it was so funny. Yeah, and I mean,
you know, going back and
forth, but the crowd, I mean
it's, it's really amazing to,
to see the,
the energy that you have a,
I think people don't see the kind of
energy that really energized standup
comedian path. They may see
it at a rock show, you know,
but this is the lead singer. Some
Freddie Mercury stuff or whatever. Right?
But when you go to see standup,
you see somebody who's really
putting out a lot of energy.
And I think it reminds people
that they can be incandescence.
They don't have to be
like these Dell embers,
which most people trudge through their
days and their cubicles and whatever.
I just dragging themselves around. But
I think seeing people really energized,
it reminds you that it is inspiring.
It reminds you that did,
you can be energetic, that you can be
powerful, that you can be commanding,
that you can be generous. Cause stand up
comedy is very generous in my opinion.
Cause so vulnerable.
I mean,
you're out there like I made to get
to get a laugh or not, you know,
like I did the acting and I
didn't do much accommodated some,
but I mostly did like the serious stuff.
And if the theater is quiet,
you can just pretend that they're
really moved and you know,
crying and all that sort of stuff.
But if you're going for laughter,
I mean it's the hair, it's not,
it's hanging out there. Right.
And so I think I'm not gonna want to
tell you your job because of course,
you know what,
a million times better than I do.
But what I really love about the stand
up is just that openness, the honesty,
the vulnerability,
and the energy.
It's funny that you should call it
generous to a lot of people think of it as
selfish because what you're trying to,
you,
you're the only reason why you're being
vulnerable because you're hoping that
you're gonna get a laugh.
You know your you're yet,
but you kind of and make them alive. The
life has to come honest, right? I mean,
if you bomb, nobody laughs out of
generosity. Right? That's true.
And there's ha yeah, or like, and then,
then the [inaudible] has come out of
the woodwork and then you're fighting a
losing battle and all that.
Now I do.
I feel anybody who provides services of
vulnerability and when you're out there
selling your CD's on the street,
poets is a vulnerability.
And so I view it as a very generous
thing to stand up, come clean is still,
of course you get paid and
you know [inaudible] nobody.
It's not like self sacrifice.
You enjoy what you do,
but the audience has to know that you
really care about them having a good time
in order for it to work.
I stay around after the show and take
pictures with everybody have to do that
and you get a helicopter to your layer
and a right Smith could take the Atlanta
tunnels or whatever you do. That to me
is a part of the the the generosity idea.
Yeah. I think it's important
that reinforces the
relationship that aren't even
appreciate them very much and the,
you know,
I'd be happy to take pictures with them
and if it takes an hour and a half out
of my day after the show's
over and that's great. Fine.
So far for real work there at that point,
what I need to lie down and get me some
cold competence and show 'em I actually
put in work that's a, what is the
prep if you don't get the curtain?
Well right now I'm working
on a lot of new material.
So right now there's a lot of writing
involved during the day. The day of show,
I like to sit down in front of my
computer at least three or four hours
and write because it really like fires
up all my synopsis and Co Coalesces All
these ideas together.
And then before the show I write things
down physically in longhand form.
But like, um, the day of the show,
like all this stuff that I wrote
about the Toronto Mayor of all that,
that was all I wrote that the day
that was all new material that I wrote
specifically because of this
silly guy. It's crazy. Yeah,
it's amazing. It's about to good stuff.
I'd forgotten about him cause you know,
I kind of blank out on politics as
much as possible cause I know it's like
dandelion fluff in the winter. It'll sting
your eyes, but that's my prep. Um, I,
I feel like I can definitely
do shows without that.
I mean I can just go and do a show, would
not, you know, I have enough material,
I could just go and do a show
right now. Like, you know,
open that door and there's comedy club
and they get on stage and it'll work out.
But to do it best, I have
to prepare, I have to write,
especially when the materials new,
there's like a lot of stuff that I have
to make sure that certain tag lines
after remember.
And it's like there's so much memory
involved in somebody past that half to,
and then there's also experiments. I
have to figure out what's the right path.
Like sometimes I'll, I'll open up with
this and then I'll close with that. Like,
you know, like last night I close
with all this stuff on being a Vegan.
That's,
I wouldn't give to the last line away.
But that last line was
like a brand in my head.
I like thought about that all the way.
Oh yeah. Go see the shallow if yeah.
Listening to this.
But that last line was like,
that was the perfect choice for me.
Oh, thank you. Well, that's how you want
to end it. Boom. Thanks. Tonight. Yeah.
Leave them wanting more. Yeah. Um,
I wanted to ask you, because I,
I, this is something that I ask of, uh,
pretty much anybody who I think is a
thinker is like looking at this crazy life
that we live. Do you have,
do you have a positive
yeah.
Outlook for the, for
humans, for culture. Do you,
did you think that we're going
to work this out? Do you,
are you a voice of doom guy or you, uh,
do you think like, you know what, I,
I think this is actually moving
in the right direction ultimately.
Yeah.
Yes. Yeah. How long? Like guy,
after so many words and the most important
question they give you one, but, uh,
I think that
okay,
the world will go how the most important
and energetic people will make it go.
Right. So I don't believe
that I'm along for the ride.
I am not a big movement in
history kind of guy. You know,
like aliens are Marxists starting
to get old bullshit and technical,
but they all believe that,
that he's big historical movements.
Then you know that the, the Zeitgeists
and this and that and the other end,
we're all just kind of along
for the ride. Like, you know,
eat grits on the back of the hippo.
I don't believe that.
I believe in the single great willpower,
individual theory of history that when
people who have ability and intelligence
and passion and commitment,
they're the ones who make the world
go in a particular direction, right?
Founding fathers did,
did it one way and it went I think at
a pretty positive direction. You know,
once the slaves and women got caught up
with the all men are equal kind of thing,
it makes it a pretty positive direction.
You look at Rosa PM,
the reign of terror in the French
revolution abandoned a break.
They had direction. If
you look at, um, um, the,
the Soviets and the
Russian revolution in 1917,
a lending and company [inaudible]
seriously bad direction and killed like 70
million people in the Soviet Empire,
right? But these are all individuals,
all individuals with particular
abilities making choices.
So I don't believe that the world is going
to get better and less people who can
make it get better. I think in in entropy
as things get worse, right? I mean, the,
the, the lowest common denominator and
the worst demagogues tend to take over,
but you can really fight against that.
And I'm a single hero of theory
of history. Like you just,
you take a stand as best you can and you
shine that light as bright as possible.
And then most people will simply go one
way or another based upon the willpower
of the individuals that
they listened to and,
and the clarity and the focus and
humility of the people that listened to
yourself. Um, I think that it
goes the way we want it to go,
but it's not going to go there unless
we make it go to a better place.
I think you're right. I think that's a
brilliant way of putting it too. I think,
um,
we do get energized from others and the
people that do have power and influence
do have almost an obligation to energize
people ideas. Yeah. Look, if, if,
if you know how to do the Heimlich
and someone's choking on a fish bone,
go help that person. You know, if you
could swim and someone's drowning,
go help that person.
You have ideas to make the world better
that you think we don't do express them.
Yeah, I mean there's, I
mean I don't believe in hand
chosen positive obligations.
Like if you choose a contract and
you're bound by that contract,
I don't think you have to put your
kind of a Dick if you don't, you know,
like if you're like,
oh I don't wanna give that
guy a tracheotomy because
this Ravioli is really good.
Even though you could
say if the guy's life,
it's not like you should be thrown in
jail for that. But it's really Douchey,
you know?
And I think if you have verbal abilities
and you have skills and you have energy
and your education and you have some
capacity and given how easy it is to,
to broadcast to the world by God,
you kind of owe it to the future.
You know?
Cause all the great stuff that we have
was people putting themselves on the line
in the past. You know, all the grain,
like the freedoms that we have, the,
the political freedoms,
all people fighting hard and a hell
of a lot harder than we have to fight.
You know,
the guys are there,
the founding fathers they face down
in the British Army for God sakes.
They could've gotten muskets
through the head, right?
And Musket ball through the head.
Why do we go,
oh maybe some people might say
bad things about me online.
It's not exactly Joan of arc stuff,
right? So we have an incredible platform.
We have so little downside to,
to bringing light to the world that
that's what drives me every day is just I
want, and especially again, when
you're coming down, you really your,
your whole timeframe extent, it's
not about your life. It's about,
and now my daughter's going to outlive
me, but like 40 years, I hope, right?
50 years.
And it really is about,
I just can't let the assholes take
over cause assholes love to do,
to be in charge.
Right.
And the problem is good people to add
that bossy because good people like live
and let live. And you know, I didn't want
to be in your face and in your business.
And you know what? I can to separate
ourselves, love to be in charge.
And they keep congregating
at the top of power.
And I don't want to be at the top of
power. I don't want to be a politician.
I don't want to have power over others.
I think that's the ring
has to go in the fire.
There's no way that they use in our,
and so the problem is that bad people
are just anal and motivated and Douchey
and power hungry and they just work
like assholes to get power over others.
And good people are like,
wow,
I don't even want that power cause I'm
happy and I'm in love. And you know,
I've got a great life and so I really
don't want to boss everyone else around.
But we have through this technology,
we don't have to have political
power to have an effect.
And we don't have to be a professor and
teach maybe 5,000 people. They're not,
we'll Korea or write some book
that maybe 10,000 people read.
1 million people can listen to this
from what you and I spending a couple of
hours having a great fucking conversation.
I mean, Ooh, what matters that we,
you know, and we can do that now. First
Time in history. It's interesting.
There's no burning at the stake there.
We're not getting burned alive as witches
were not being thrown into, you know,
Russian lines like soldier Nixon.
I mean we have this, it's when,
when we have a great conversation,
the world hopefully gets the nuggets of
wisdom and we turned the ship a little
bit more towards the light. I agree. I
think there's a great way to end this.
Alright, thank you so much. [inaudible]
your website for my listeners,
Joe rogan.net Joe Rogan Demos,
freedom Maine radio.com. Um,
all books are free or podcasts are free.
Now advertising because I
have the business sense of
a boxer g string and your
youtube channel. Oh yes. youtube.com
forward slash freedom and reading. Well,
you know,
I don't,
I think you have a great business sense
because you've accumulated this massive
fallen sort of few, few wanted to
sell something. Now it'd be the time.
How to think about it builds up the
awesome core audience. So that's right.
And I've held off from Sally something.
So the first thing I sell is going to
be great baby. Just some gold actually.
Well, I am. I mean, it's not for sale, but
a documentary is coming out pretty soon.
I've had good fortunate to work with Sean
Lennon and some other great musicians
too. What's the documentary? It's
called truth because I'm very modest.
It's basically a,
it's a documentary about what's wrong
with the world and how we should fix it
for, on philosophic. Cause
let me know when it comes out.
I would have you promoted. Thank you
very much Joe time. Thank you very much.
There's a lot of fun.
[inaudible].